Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, we're fine.
We're okay.
Welcome back, Master.
Master.
Hello.
Du.
Hi.
Hello.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
What's so funny?
I did this.
You hear it?
You like that?
You like the double audio?
Kinda sounds cool now, actually.
Wait, you guys don't hear the double audio?
Congrats on 200k.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
No?
The whole time you've heard the single audio?
Oh.
That's so weird.
I don't hear a double.
Definitely double.
Yeah, it was double for a second.
Right at the start.
Okay, I feel like I'm going crazy.
You guys like the new emotes?
Excuse me, waiter.
This ghost is too tricky.
Bustin'.
You like them?
They're so fun.
Thank you, Tuna.
Thank you, Wolfie.
For the new ones.
This is not all of them.
There will be more.
Sai, welcome to the membership.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Amy, thank you for the gift.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Yeah.
More?
Yeah, I'm going to get more.
I have...
I don't remember how many more slots I have.
But I have more.
I have to get them commissioned.
Fun.
Thank you for the 10.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you so much.
All the slots for sure.
I think so.
I don't know...
I don't remember how many it is exactly.
But...
Earlier...
Actually, just a half hour ago, I got off with finishing recording with Mataro the next podcast episode.
And we had talked for two hours before that.
So I'm a little sleepy.
Hi.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
You what?
I did the podcast.
Good morning.
And...
No, I don't want to do a short stream because I want to get through this.
I've been having fun playing it.
But...
And then before that, this morning, I had a meeting.
So...
It's been a busy day for me.
I've just been...
I've just been in my...
On my computer the whole time.
So...
Yeah.
But I'm excited to play Ghost Trick.
The reason I say all that is because if my voice...
If my...
If my voice starts to get weird, it's because I've been talking all day.
The number of stamps increased.
Yeah!
I got a new stamp.
Yeah.
What did you have a meeting about?
I can't say.
Oh my gosh, and yesterday I went to the doctor's office and I was so sad.
I hate going to the... It was... Nothing bad happened.
I hate going to the doctor's office.
So... Yeah.
Let's...
Wow, this doctor... Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
Did you see that Konami is bringing back the Metal Gear Solid Ducks?
Specifically Ocelot, Otacon, and Psycho Mantis.
Have fun tricking ghosts.
Thanks!
I did see that they posted about it.
Wait, so there's no more... No new Solid Snake?
I think I...
I think I want the Ocelot Duck, but I think I'm okay with the other ones.
Been waiting for this milestone chat since 2021!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I only have Solid Snake.
I hope you are healthy.
I think I am.
What am I gonna do?
Die again?
Hahahaha!
Yeah.
But uh...
How do you do the...
The emote with the little... with the... with the...
With the wind?
I wanted to do it with the clown.
Looks like he was passing a little gas.
4AM can't sleep, but gonna watch Pinto!
I hope that I can help you sleep a little bit more.
Oh, is it Dash?
Quack, sir.
Hahahaha!
Yeah, it's like the...
Fart Unleashed!
Oh my gosh!
Hahahaha!
Stop it, you guys!
Stop it!
Okay.
So last time on Ghost Trick, we...
Um...
We, uh...
Found out that we are dead.
And we...
We have special ghost powers where we can possess any inanimate thing.
We're trying to figure out who killed us.
We also have special powers where we can go back in time.
And save people from becoming dead, because we saved a dog and a lady.
What?
You're dead?
I'm dead!
Yeah, we saved Missile, the best dog ever.
We saved a lady.
We don't know her yet.
And there were some blue guys.
I love Missile.
I love Missile!
Dad?
Let's continue.
What's on the extras?
I think this is like all the background...
Wait, challenges.
Oh!
Oh, wait!
Cleared ghost trick.
75% of what?
I've already cleared 75% of something.
Mystery of a secret.
Wait, maybe I...
Don't look at that!
And we have illustrations.
Oh, look at that!
This is such a good wallpaper for...
Oh, I can zoom in and out.
For my streams.
Oh my gosh, this is the one I use for my streams.
Oh!
The Junkyard!
That's one of the guys.
Tippy Toes?
I don't remember his name.
There's a girl sick in this bed.
Lamp!
Nearsighted Jigo!
Down!
Thanks for the tiny gift and thank you!
Thank you so much!
Alright, let's get started though.
We started...
at...
Well, they're both the same.
Let's go!
Oh, someone else just died!
We have to save the girl again!
Don't we?
Well, I don't know.
What was her name?
Emily?
Okay.
Oh gosh.
We're tricking again.
We can swivel the desk.
Okay.
Now we're going ghost again.
And we're... Oh, we can examine the notebook?
What's up with this blinding pink notebook?
Lynn!
That was her shot.
Sorry.
Her name.
Her name was Lynn.
I read shot.
Somebody stuck it behind the bookcase at a haphazard angle.
Maybe that's the superintendent's way of tidying up.
Okay.
Her shot.
Sorry.
Oh, we can turn on the lamp.
We're showing them the notebook.
Notebook.
There's also the book up here that we can't get up to yet.
Motor.
Oh!
Ew!
What are these?
There's like a whole contraption down here.
Interesting.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
She's probably still sleepy.
Matryoshka.
Unconscious this time as well, eh?
How's the audio, by the way?
Oh!
She's awake!
Where...
am I?
Oh my god, she's awake!
She's awake!
She's coming too?
You're gonna extract him too?
What happened to me?
Audio's good?
Oh god.
Excuse me.
Are you ignoring me?
Oh, uh, sorry!
I'm still not used to talking with dead people, you see.
Dead?
It's in red.
So I'm dead, huh?
Hmm.
Try as I might, I can't seem to remember who I am.
She's starting to remind me of me.
Who am I?
Everybody seems to call you Lin, if that's any help.
Lin, huh?
Pretty cute name.
And apparently you're a detective too.
Detective?
You mean that super cool kind of cop that solves crimes and upholds justice?
Sounds like a pretty subjective description, but yes, that kind of detective, quote-unquote.
I love that this game has two buttons.
Ghost and trick.
Um, wait a minute.
Um, actually, are you starting to remember something?
Oh my god!
Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the five kete!
Thank you!
We umi neko now.
Oh.
Is my chair okay?
There's no time to lose!
Something really unusual is going down in this town tonight.
What?
Remak thanks for the five kete!
Yeah, I certainly won't argue with the really unusual part.
This song is so fun!
That's not your face, you know.
Take another look.
You're the dead one.
Oh, right, of course.
It'd be pretty heinous if I looked like this, I guess, wouldn't it?
I don't know if heinous is the right word.
I just took things for the five kete dude!
There we go!
Now this is more like it!
She was just...
She was actually stealing that guy's identity.
Something really unusual is going on in this town tonight.
Could it have anything to do with my death, I wonder?
This is my 7am alarm.
You wake up to this?
Oh gosh, this is triggering for you then, probably.
Identity theft is not a joke.
Sorry.
Sorry, I didn't mean to.
I'm just gonna put my...
You remember that guy that put his social security on, like, a truck and drove it around New York?
And then said, No one will steal my identity.
It's protected by this company!
And then it all got stolen.
Hahahaha Hahahaha
Hahahaha Hahahaha Don't ever tell people... Don't ever challenge people, you know?
What is going on in this town tonight?
Don't ask me.
I'm dead.
I don't remember anything.
I can't remember a thing.
I think it's probably cause I'm dead.
Grr... Everything is so confusing!
Can't you do something?
Oh wait...
If he protects her, or brings her back, will she be able to remember who we are, just like Missile?
The dog?
Hey, you're asking the wrong guy!
Same for you, Mint?
What do you mean?
That I have no memories?
Or don't challenge me?
Hahaha But I've got some things to ask you about.
Oh!
She's not gonna remember me though.
What about her death?
So I died, huh?
Yes, apparently.
I'm very sorry.
How could this have happened?
After I just passed my test, finally...
Wait, she remembers!
My exciting career of catching the bad guys has just begun!
And now look at me!
Why did I have to go and die?
In an old junkyard like this?
Poor Shock...
Oh wait, poor Shock...
Hahaha Poor kid!
The shock is setting in!
Poor Shock...
And so I told her everything that happened tonight.
About ghost tricks, possessing and manipulating objects.
And about going back four minutes before a person's death.
Poor Shock...
This actually isn't the first time you died tonight, you know?
That's so freaky!
Oh my gosh, can you imagine?
You were already shot and killed once before tonight!
And you saved me?
That's right!
You don't remember?
Flashback!
Oh, death!
Slip...
Let's get rid of the funky music.
Death isn't that funny, you guys.
Yes, I think I do remember something like that happening.
Vaguely.
Yes, I did get shot!
By a blue man dressed in all black!
How does she remember that?
I guess that means that even if a death is erased, the memory of it remains.
Eww!
Oh my gosh, she can remember how it hurt and everything?
The pain...
So I died twice already tonight.
You are so unlucky.
Is Mint literate?
Wish I knew what to say to her.
Guess I'll just have to wait until she recovers a little.
Hey, I bet that's some kind of a record, don't you think?
Yeah, you're probably right.
Looks like she's pretty much recovered already.
About me.
Do you remember anything about me?
Looking for the answers to the questions, Who am I?
And why was I killed?
Do you know anything that might help me?
She can't read chat.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I'm also gonna be yawning tonight.
The only thing I know right now is that my name is Sissel.
Your name is Sissel, huh?
I think so.
It rings some kind of a bell anyway.
I think I was killed tonight while I was meeting with you.
So you must at least know me.
I think.
I was meeting with you?
Yes, in the junkyard outside.
I'm EP.
I have a...
Sorry.
I'm sorry if I'm so grumpy.
I don't think I'll be grumpy.
But...
I haven't been able to sleep much the past couple of nights because of the...
What's the word?
The pinched nerve in my neck keeps me up.
So I'm sorry if I'm grumpy.
Grumpy.
I'm grumpy.
Mint's illiterate.
She can read the fine print on solid snakes.
But...
It's not fine print.
I mean, that's...
That's not what's fine about it.
But yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to sleep.
But I can't.
Because I'm...
I don't know.
I don't know, I just twist and turn, and it's all pain.
Anyway, it's coming back to me.
I remember now.
I knew it.
I knew you were the lead I needed.
But I'm so sorry.
I don't think I can help you.
She says with a smile.
Why not?
Because I don't know you.
What do you mean?
I thought you said you remembered me.
She only saw us dead.
I knew it.
She said I remembered something.
I remember the fact that I don't...
Oh.
I don't know you.
No way.
Two strangers.
So you don't know me, huh?
Nope.
Wish I did.
So do you suppose we're just two strangers who...
happened to meet tonight?
No way.
I don't think it was any accident.
Our lead, man.
Why in the world would I be way out here in the middle of nowhere for no reason?
I was asked to come here tonight.
Asked to come?
By who?
Your yawn is making me yawn.
I'm sorry!
If I have to get some coffee later, I will.
If I have to... I'm having tea right now, but if I have to have coffee, that's okay too.
Can't you kind of guess where this is going?
We were set up.
Oh, you're kidding me?
Bingo.
By you.
Oh.
I asked you to come here?
But why?
Oh.
That's not what I was getting at.
Oh my god.
Good thing she's the detective.
That's why I was going to ask you.
Oh, that's what I was going to ask you.
Why did you ask me to come here tonight?
Way out here in the middle of nowhere.
Oh my god, a love confession.
You gotta be kidding me.
It goes without saying that I don't remember.
Everything is so confusing.
Can't you do something?
Lin, I'm not saying you owe me or anything, but I have a favor to ask.
What is it?
In the next four minutes...
I didn't make a sound.
In the next four minutes, you'll probably come back to life.
When you do, do you think you could try to find...
Wait, do you think you could try to find out about me before tomorrow morning?
Yeah, I'm sleepy.
Who I am and why I was killed.
Do you guys know a way to stop yawning?
Like legitimately.
I used to have a job where I would wake up at like 4 a.m.
and I was teaching English.
And I would like have to... like I would be on...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Anonymous, thanks for the vibe gift.
Thank you.
I would like... I don't think you can.
Right?
I don't think so.
I... either.
I almost dropped my controller.
But I... I would be so tired in the morning.
And then they would like...
They would...
They would... they would... they would...
They would say... they would get on my classroom and they would tell me to stop yawning.
Or I would like pause my screen so that they wouldn't see that I was yawning.
And they'd be like, stop pausing your screen.
And I was like, I'm yawning.
And they're like, no.
It's... it's... it's... rude.
Don't yawn.
I was like, I'm sorry.
Take deeper breaths.
Won't that make you sleepy though?
I know that they don't want me to yawn so that other people won't yawn.
How am I supposed to stop myself to yawn?
Man.
I still yawn.
I'm really sorry.
But I can't make any promises.
Might as well tell you to stop sneezing.
Right?
Why not?
Are the people I taught okay?
Who knows?
Why not?
I don't remember very clearly right now.
But I think I was investigating a case tonight.
A case that is very, very important to me.
So even if I come back to life...
I don't think I'll have time to find out anything about you.
You could do it in the middle of the night.
I know that's a terrible thing to say to the person who saved my life once already.
Apparently cold drinks and cold snacks.
I have a warm drink.
I'm messing it up.
I'm really, really sorry.
I see.
That's too bad.
But I'm afraid I'm still going to ask you.
Ask me what?
Ask you to save me.
Even though I probably won't be able to help you.
I know it's selfish of me.
I really apologize.
But I just can't die.
Not yet.
Not like this.
It's alright, Mint.
Don't worry about it.
Thanks.
I'm investigating something important tonight.
I think maybe that might be the reason I was killed.
But I still want to survive.
I want to solve that case in spite of all of that.
Am I out of line?
Didn't I tell you a minute ago you don't owe me?
I'm certainly not going to treat your life like some kind of bargaining chip.
I'll save you.
What you do after that is up to you.
He's so awesome.
He's so cool.
Thank you.
Are you ready to go back?
Back to four minutes before you got shot?
Yeah, rewind time.
Okay.
Four minutes before death.
We gotta see what's going on.
Okay.
Lin's second death.
I'm heading back in time now to rewind.
Rewrite her fate.
Faced with those circumstances, she could have just lied and promised to help me.
But she didn't.
That's when I knew I could try.
Trust her.
So much sleepy.
After this, I'm going to get coffee.
Don't worry.
Okay, here we go.
We're watching her.
She's on the phone.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Yes!
Is this the guy that shot her?
Detective!
Is everything okay?
I was hungry.
So I was trying to get something delivered.
What?
Don't do that!
I'm sorry.
You should leave jobs like that to me.
Is chicken alright?
He's so cute.
You...
One chicken dinner.
Winner winner.
What a nice guy.
That's okay.
I'm not feeling very hungry anymore.
Where was he going to order from?
I would like to go back to the station for a minute though.
You would?
I'm afraid I can't let you do that.
I wish Mint would teach me English.
What do you want to learn?
What do you want to know?
Minty, do you know about the new auto-generated chat summary that YouTube implemented?
Seeing it pop up in your stream is decently accurate.
I have!
Wait, if we keep saying chicken, will it start saying like...
The chat is talking about chicken dinner.
That they'll be winners for eating it.
I never see them.
I never see the...
I only see the ones that people screenshot and then post on Twitter later.
But I don't see it myself.
Winner winner, chicken dinner.
Chicken dinner, chicken dinner, chicken dinner, chicken dinner.
It might be mobile only.
I think so.
Did someone say chicken?
Why can't you let me go back to the station?
Inspector Cabanela is on his way.
He'll be here any minute.
Oh, there he is.
Wow!
Evening, patrolman.
Sir.
Good evening, Inspector Cabanela, sir.
Chickens are the new melons.
Nice chickens.
Nice work.
Now, do me a favor and take a little patrol around outside, would you?
This guy killed me.
No way, but it came in through the window.
That's a nice fellow.
Yes, sir.
I love this little officer guy.
He's so cute.
Yo, how's it going, baby?
Inspector Cabanela, what are you doing here?
Imagine him with an Elvis...
I am doing Elvis voice.
This is not...
Is it not good?
Wait, I am doing an Elvis voice.
Is it not...
Is it not a good Elvis voice?
You hear it?
Six out of ten?
It's either Elvis or Johnny Bravo.
I thought the special...
Oh, oh, oh...
Daft Elf!
Thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you so much.
I thought the special investigation unit had an important...
top secret assignment tonight.
What does that matter at a time like this...
when my Lin's in chri...
My Lin?
My Lin's in crisis.
I appreciate it, sir.
Who are you?
Are you my...
Yeah, wait a minute.
Did you just say crisis?
Don't tell me I'm being suspected?
Uh-oh.
Suspected of shooting that pointy-haired man in the red suit?
I mean, I've never even met the guy before.
Hmm.
Never, baby.
Oh, well, uh...
Uh-oh.
Before tonight, I mean.
He asked me to meet him here.
Hmm.
Well, uh...
He said he had important information about the big case I'm working on.
He's the one who contacted me!
I see, I see.
But it's funny, isn't it?
I took a look at the list of cases your station is handling right now.
And I didn't see you listed as involved on any big cases.
We're rogue.
She's rogue.
You can't stop me, Dad.
You're not my dad.
You might be my dad.
But my dad wouldn't call me baby!
You know I don't suspect you, baby.
I'm just trying to clear things up.
Hubba hubba.
Wait, what is, uh...
What does Elvis say?
Humana, humana.
Wait, what?
Hoo-yah.
Uh, wait.
What is...
It just says baby?
Hubba hubba?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
You're not the type to ever shoot anybody.
Hey, who knows you better than me, baby?
You know, if anything ever happened to you, I'd kill everyone in this room and then myself.
I'd never be able to look him in the eye again.
My dad?
Inspector Cabanela, I'm going to ask you a question.
Yeah?
And what's that?
Oh my god, she's going to get shot before she can ask.
And I want you to answer honestly.
Don't delay.
You're about to get hit!
Is it tonight?
Oh, is that when it's happening?
Honka honka!
I have no idea what you're talking about, baby.
Get down!
Oh...
That's that.
It seems to me that baby is indeed under suspicion.
By Inspector Cabanela?
No, he's not like that.
Just for the record.
Did you shoot me?
Me?
I would never do anything like that.
Anyway, it looks like the hitman fired from outside.
It'd be hard to prevent the bullet from coming in, though.
Hmm...
In any case, let's just give it a try.
Our four-minute game.
Our four-minute, twelve-hour game.
Hmm...
Trick time.
You know what?
I have an idea.
The guy who shot me is outside, right?
Looks that way, yeah?
Instead of trying to stop the bullet once it gets in here, wouldn't it be more fun to go out and stop the guy who's shooting the bullet?
I like it.
Fun, she says with eyes gleaming.
Oh boy.
You can use the telephone to move around, right?
That's right.
And I know the telephone number to the junkyard payphone, too.
But we're upstairs.
And the shot...
Meh.
I don't want to get shot again.
You know what they say.
About three strikes and you're out.
As long as you don't become a ball player, you'll probably be safe.
But the telephone thing's a good idea.
Maybe I'll give it a try.
What's she saying here?
I have a bad feeling about this.
Yes, sir.
I don't remember...
Wait.
Detective, is everything okay?
Oh, okay.
This is just to restart it.
My bad.
Let me turn ghost.
Turn ghost.
Ghost trick.
Oh, ghost.
Okay, let's see.
Where can we go to?
The motor.
Okay.
Step ladder.
Let's see what this is.
Microscope.
Photos.
What's in the photos?
These pictures are old.
What are they of?
Little fragments of rock?
We're going ghost.
The fragments are glowing.
Do you know what these are?
It's nuclear.
Radioactive.
Sorry, but I've lost my memory.
Probably not the best person to ask.
That's okay.
I was only being polite.
I didn't really think you'd know.
Ouch.
This lady's tongue can be sharp.
I can hear what you're...
She can hear what we're thinking?
I know.
Good one.
No way.
She can hear what we're thinking?
No.
That's so scary.
What could this be?
It looks like a giant nail clipper.
You think so?
Do you know what it is?
Why did you have to ask me?
Couldn't you see I was looking away evasively?
I'm sorry.
It's one of those science-y things that scientists use.
Ordinary people like us don't have to know what it is.
You're a detective.
You need to know everything.
I don't remember what science is.
Mom, where does science come from?
But it's apparently something Lin doesn't like very much.
She doesn't like or doesn't know?
Okay.
Do we know what's in the notebook?
Because this seems kind of important.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's mine.
Isn't it adorable?
Cecil skipped first grade.
Why isn't your adorable notebook in your pocket?
I panicked, okay?
Don't you shove things in the bookcase when you panic?
Who are you calling anyway?
It was personal business.
I don't like the sound of that, Missy.
Oh, we still can't go through anything down here.
Oh, I was going to say, can I even get to the telephone?
All right, let's try dialing it.
Micmac, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Oh, that's funny.
What's the matter?
This telephone doesn't seem to be working right now.
Usually the telephone line glows red, but it's dark right now.
Oh, isn't it?
In the four minutes, we can't use it.
Apparently.
Yeah, in this four minutes before death, we can't use the phone lines.
Yes, yes, yes.
I remember now.
As long as the lines are closed like this, it looks like we can't go anywhere.
But I want to stop that criminal.
Where else can we go?
Notebook.
There's a lot of stuff going on down here.
Wait, I'm a little ball.
Can I move?
No.
We can't get that book either still.
What do you mean?
Let's see if I swivel it, if he does anything.
This guy is unfazed.
He's like, eh, I've seen worse.
I know.
This ain't my first poltergeist.
I don't have anything else over here, really.
So there's not really a reason.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna go over here.
Oh wait, I said I did it earlier though.
I wanted to turn the lamp on so that they would look at the notebook.
There.
Huh?
That's Lin's notebook.
Hey, wait a minute.
I did this earlier.
La la la.
La la la la.
I thought she was practicing a dance move when I came in.
Nope, that was definitely suspicious.
No question.
I'd better report this.
I wonder if I can make the call without her noticing.
You little snitch.
Huh?
What's up?
I've been watching Lin just like you told me to.
And I noticed something suspicious.
Sus?
When the notebook is sus.
Hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi.
You did?
So Inspector Cabanilla was right.
She was hiding her notebook when I came in.
Her notebook, eh?
Yes, yes, sir.
In a very suspicious manner.
And in a very conspicuous place.
Just throwing all the memes out there.
Okay, but when you think of Among Us, do you not think of Five Nights at Freddy's 2?
Why would I?
I don't know.
What's the connection?
Okay, someone will be over later.
Don't let on you noticed anything.
Okay...
Look at that!
The phone line is glowing red!
I bet it would work if we tried it now.
I bet you're right.
The detective he's talking to is outside in the junkyard.
I mean FNAF also has vents.
So true!
So true.
And that's where the horrible hitman who's after me is too.
Are they?
I guess so.
Go to there.
The most ominous lamp I've ever... What?
The Notebook starring acclaimed actor Ryan Gosling?
He's not in that.
Is he?
I've been waiting for you.
Eek!
What are you?
A test clamp.
That sounds like an old grandpa.
Sounds like an old grandpa.
Just call me Ray.
Grandpa Ray.
You just have to get the grandpa part in there somewhere, don't you?
Well, we didn't have that context before.
Interesting.
We're souls.
We can choose any appearance we like.
Which means you have no intention of showing us what you really look like, right?
Now then.
About that gunshot that took your life.
So Mint could also turn into a lamp?
I mean, I guess if I wanted to...
Why?
Do you want me to turn into a lamp?
Like anamorphs into a lamp?
The Notebook with Ryan Gosling.
No, it's not!
I'm looking this up.
If it's really Ryan Gosling in the Notebook...
I'll eat my shoe.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's
not Ryan Gosling!
Oh my god.
No way!
Wait, who is Nicholas Sparks then?
Wait.
I don't know.
That shoe tastes good.
Don't use the cloud emoji!
No way!
The author of the book the movie is based on.
No!
No way!
I thought you guys were kidding.
I thought you were kidding because of the Ryan Gosling meme.
But he doesn't have a beard!
Time for lunch.
Okay, I'll eat it.
I'll eat it at the end of stream, okay?
Let me get through the stream first.
I heard your shoes taste just like tree frogs.
Stop the cloud emoji.
I heard it.
Way up on the upper level.
A scant few minutes from now.
The hitman is probably getting his rifle ready right now.
Alright, I'm going in.
I'll get in with those ghost trick thingies.
I'm very sorry, young lady.
But how does it taste?
No!
That's okay, man.
Surely Ryan Gosling isn't his real name.
You don't have those powers.
No, sir.
What?
Why not?
I'm afraid I don't know the reason.
But only a special few have the powers of the dead.
What?
Are you saying I'm not special?
That's not fair.
I got a trophy for participating in a game when I was a kid.
I'm special.
Anyway, we don't have much time.
Come on and hop in.
Ooh, he's greeting us to enter his body.
There he goes.
He's gonna go upstairs.
Carry on, boys.
Fate changed.
Um...
Okay.
We're going crazy.
If I fold this here, can we go up?
Ooh, nice.
Nice.
Oh, it's this part again.
Refrigerator.
Oh, there's nothing.
Nothing here.
There's nothing.
Your shoes are chocolate though, right?
Yeah.
Thought bubble above?
It's okay, I don't want... I don't want the hints.
I don't want the hints.
Oh there he goes!
Oh my gosh, he's on the stairs!
It's so crazy.
But we gotta hop inside the lamp.
Ray.
Trick.
Oh.
What do you mean by hop in then?
What do you mean by that?
Let's see, what other things can we perform tricks on?
We can ghost trick...
me.
Maybe we do this part again.
Ooh!
Time is passing!
Oh wait.
This needs to be on, right?
Oh my god!
Oh that was close.
Whee!
Why are you taking the bike?
Uh...
No, no, no!
Okay, we saw him take the bike.
There he goes!
We should get going ourselves.
Feels like we lost, you know?
If there's one thing I hate, it's losing a race.
I wasn't aware we were in a race with the inspector.
Think barber pull stripes.
You're red and he's white.
And it's a race to the top.
Maybe I should just indulge her and try again.
Okay.
Yeah, let's try this again.
Oh!
I cleared...
I cleared a song?
Wait, what's going on?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Turn...
on.
Uh...
There's nothing else we can do here.
Maybe we were supposed to turn it on?
Or turn it off?
When he was up here.
Mmm...
Fun's for a good barbecue sauce to go with the leathery taste of...
Thanks.
Yeah, I think we missed the bike.
Oh, but we see who's the guy!
Oh my gosh.
We see the guy though!
Look, there he is!
Way up there!
The horrible hitman!
I think his name is actually Tengu, but I guess that doesn't matter.
Let's go grind him to pieces!
I wish he wouldn't use such violent expressions.
Besides, I don't see any cores that will get us over there.
I think we might have missed our chance already.
Timing is everything.
Okay.
Okay, sir.
Okay,
let's do it after the fate change.
Okay.
He's always one step ahead.
I know!
That's okay.
We know that she's gonna die.
We know how to get up there.
And fold!
Squidward!
Tortellini!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
What is this?
What did they say anyway?
That horrible hitman that's after me is upstairs, isn't he?
Apparently.
In other words, we can't stop him if we stay down here.
See?
I didn't need the hint, you guys!
I was going...
I was already on my way up there!
I was already on my way up there.
Now, we wait.
It's time to hunt down that horrible hitman.
He must be around here somewhere preparing to take his shot.
Once...
Step ahead, Minto!
Let's try to find him fast.
I'm going to make...
I'm going to make good and sure he understands what happens to people who point guns at others.
There's a gleam.
So!
What if maybe...
The spotlight highlights him, maybe?
That's what we might have to do.
Time is passing.
He might, like, kick it.
If he gets so scared.
What did I do wrong?
Okay.
I'm going ghost!
What did I do wrong?
There's nothing else we can do.
What if I roll the tire?
Might have been a dumb idea.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's nothing over here.
Okay.
Can he jump to his bike?
What are you...
Oh my gosh.
He's dancing his way.
Go!
Oh my gosh.
He's dancing his way.
I thought that I was going to startle him...
with the light.
You guys...
It's... I just...
Oh yeah.
Because I see now the bike is lit up.
Guys!
I had a good idea.
Okay.
Here he comes.
Nice!
I'm going ghost.
There he is.
Spotlight him.
Spotlight him!
I see my target.
Time to go to work.
I'll be head of the Hitman division by next month now for sure.
There he is!
The horrible Hitman!
We said this before.
We have to stop him from shooting.
Fast!
Oh!
Open!
Time is passing!
Turn the spotlight on!
Yeah!
Bozo!
We put a stop to that shot at least.
I'm so...
I'm safe now, right?
Well that changed your fate a little but it didn't avert it completely.
We're not done yet.
The Hitman is a professional and he really, really wants to be head of the division apparently.
Now get blinded Bozo.
This guy.
This stupid guy behind us.
I vouched for you.
I vouched for you but you can't even notice a Hitman coming from behind the car.
I doubt blocking a shot here and there is really going to stop him.
We have to kill him.
We have to splat him.
Just like the last guy.
If you want to rough him up a little bit I promise I won't put it in my report.
You made that bet knowing well that ghosts don't wear shoes.
What?
No.
That was my...
Oh she's so...
Stop it.
Okay.
I was going to say something else.
But I don't want to go to the bathroom just yet.
Let's think of something else before he gets us shot in.
Fate has been changed.
We're gonna pedal to the metal with this guy.
Pedal, pedal, pedal.
Oh we're stuck here.
Just kidding.
We're gonna bicycle.
Close the door.
Oh.
Come here.
Come here, nightstick.
There we go.
We gotta get the next spotlight.
Oh my gosh.
Don't you notice him?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
This guy is so oblivious.
Your hat is too low on your face.
You can't see anything in front of you.
Oh my god.
If I want that position, I have to be careful of even the least bit of light.
Division head is my ambition for this year.
Next year, my motto will be If I want to be director, I have to be careful of even the least bit of scandal.
So it sounds like he won't show up in spots where a light is on.
And next year, I'm going to spread some nasty scandalous rumors about him.
Wee woo.
Flashing light!
What?
Wait, I didn't see him.
Hey, did you turn that flashing light on?
Wasn't me.
It went off all by itself.
Scared the heck out of me.
Well, just make sure you lay off it.
Don't want to waste any electricity.
Wow, they're so...
They're so conscious.
Have things gotten that tight?
That's pretty sad.
They're really putting the squeeze on us lately about using too much power at sites.
They won't even let us use all of our searchlights at once.
Interesting.
Oh boy.
We ought to be free to do at least that much.
Especially on a dark night like tonight.
Uh oh.
I think I need to follow this guy now.
Time is passing.
Maybe I was wrong.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Budget cuts.
What are you gonna do exactly?
Hey, I told you.
I think if we...
If we make it so we can't do the shot from here, it'll at least keep the spotlight on on the other location, you know?
So, he won't be able to go back to the other car, but he also won't be able to get it here.
That's what I think.
I told you to lay off that thing.
And I told you, it wasn't me!
Uh oh.
I think I might know what's going on here.
This is the work of...
You know.
Hey!
Shut up!
You're creeping me out!
But you know as well as I do, the only explanation for mischief like this is...
I'm not gonna get caught here, am I?
Inspector Cabanela!
So they tell tales about him as though he's a ghost, eh?
Inspector Cabanela is really a very nice person.
G-g-g-ghost!
Oh, jinkies!
Wait, so if I just stay here...
It doesn't feel like I'm doing so much.
You're allegedly a ghost.
What's the best trick?
Um...
I don't know.
What if I do this?
Nothing happens.
That's funny.
I thought this lever was for swinging the crane arm around.
I'd like to swing that horrible hitman around.
This crane.
I wonder if there's some other way we can use it.
Oh wait.
Uh...
My bad.
Can we reach the light?
We can.
But if I do this...
I would have to go back with the other guy to get back up to the crane.
But then that one turns off.
Okay, wait, I think I messed up.
One of the lights went out.
There are three lights here altogether.
Apparently we can't have all three of them on at once.
Our station is crazy cheap when it comes to electricity.
So just another detective could see what he was doing the other day.
I had to pedal my bicycle in place to work the headlamp.
Oh my god.
Very sad tale indeed.
Sounds like they're taking things way too far.
Okay.
So I'm gonna turn this one off.
I need to get...
Wait, come back!
Uh oh.
Wait, come back officer!
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
Sir.
Time is passing!
Oh my god, I hear him!
I hear him!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Okay.
See,
the bike I couldn't pedal.
Can I pedal this one?
No.
Let's wait for our little guy here.
Let's wait for our guy.
Then we'll do it again at the other side.
Then maybe try something with the...
what the...
Oh my god.
Why?!
Oh my gosh, why?
Oh my god, I'm not gonna make it!
No!
Where is he gonna shoot her from?!
Let's see.
Raise here.
Oh, neat.
Okay.
Lower?
Oh, shoot!
Such power and such speed.
I bet that would put a nice stop to my horrible hitman.
Okay, how do we move it?
If it just stopped, then that would be fine.
Phoenix, thanks for the membership!
Welcome, welcome.
If it killed him, would I be obliged to save him?
Anyway, let's just focus on the stopping part.
Apparently, thinking about things too deeply isn't something you like to do.
Just the right amount.
That's the way detectives think about things.
How do I move this?
Oh, I just love stamping out evil.
It makes me feel so alive!
Except for the fact that you can't.
You're dead.
Open.
What?
Okay.
Everybody, if I ask to open the umbrella, don't let me do it.
Wait, did we see this before?
Wait, I think we can pretty safely assume this was the murder weapon.
Wait, I think we did.
That pistol.
Same model as the pistol you detected?
Yeah, we saw this before.
You don't think it's Lin, do you?
This is not good.
Blah blah blah, we've read all this.
Oh, then we made it go off!
That's right.
It's a good recap.
This is the act of somebody who is jealous of my abilities as a detective.
Sorry if I'm not reading all of it, I'm just gonna...
Oh!
There it is.
Her death.
Time's up.
Okay.
Have to look for the right time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh no, we have to go all the way from...
Oh my gosh.
That's a long amount of time we have to...
Oh, wait!
Oh, okay, interesting.
We can't do anything with the pedal.
We only pedaled to get down here.
How do I get up there?
Also, see, I think the street lamp can be possessed?
Hmm...
Oh, look, my bad.
Mister!
Come back, please.
Thank you, sir.
What else can...
Yeah, the lamp can also be...
Hmm...
La-la-la-la.
But the lever didn't do anything.
Follow this guy.
I wonder if we do anything on the...
The guitar is still all filled with bullet holes.
That's so funny.
Raise!
Okay.
And if I lowered it...
It didn't really do anything.
No.
I'm just confused how to get over there.
Oh no!
Wait!
I can make it!
Oh, I can't make it!
I can't!
I can't make it!
Oh no, he's gonna shoot her!
Oh no, please!
Don't shoot!
Oh no!
Come back, sir!
Oh my god, he's loading his gun.
This one!
We need him to show up at this one!
Wait, but this one...
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, wait!
Which one did it turn...
Oh, no, yeah, because we already turned it off.
Okay.
Okay, now come back, please!
Sir?
Please come back.
Thank you.
Okay.
Good thing we turned off that spotlight right there first.
And then...
Oh, that's where you show up, eh?
Big dummy.
This is quite a distance from the target.
But I can't work under a spotlight after all.
Never mind.
A shot like this is nothing for a man of my skill.
I mean, you're a sniper.
That's what you're supposed to do, distance.
Mr. Division Head seems to like dark, gloomy places.
I'd be happy to throw him in a dark, gloomy cell.
Or into dark, gloomy hell!
When did I become her assistant?
Wait, wait, wait!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
No!
What?
Whoa, they talked?
No way!
Okay.
Time is passing.
Just a little bit more.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm going, ghost!
It's over for you.
Mister...
Oh my god.
Did you hear her scream just now?
I'm telling you, it wasn't me!
Oh my gosh, I killed two people tonight.
Dang.
I've killed two people just to save one girl!
And a dog.
I mean the dog was worth it.
But what if the girl is evil?
There.
We found a nice dark spot for our gloom-loving hitman.
I think your death has been erased.
Again.
Fate averted!
Does Lynn seem evil?
She's not.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I can't...
I don't know if I can trust her spiky hair.
Why not?
I wonder.
Huh?
Why don't I have powers like yours?
If I could do things like you do, it could really help me pursue my case.
Why only this special few, huh?
It's not fair!
That's the same thing the little doggy said, too.
Well, I'm jealous of you, actually, because you get to stay alive.
You are?
Why?
Because your life can be saved.
Even if you die again tonight, I can save you with my ghost tricks.
Nobody can save my life, though.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm dead, lady.
You should appreciate your life.
I'm dead.
These powers of the dead.
Why have they chosen me?
Will I find the answer to that question?
Tonight?
I bet we will.
Well, not in tonight's stream, maybe, but I don't know.
Sissel, I'm so sorry.
Well, you're free to do as you please now.
I guess this is goodbye, detective.
Will we ever see each other again?
If you ever want to see me again, all you have to do is die.
Okay.
Got it.
I was kidding.
Well, guess we'd better be getting back to the present.
Cool.
Isn't that cool to say, die for me?
Lynn is cute so she's worth saving.
True.
Lynn has escaped death for a second time.
But that doesn't mean she's out of the water yet.
I'd better go see how she's doing.
Can you imagine?
What if you just, like.
What if you do the four minutes before death over and over again?
That's just Steins Gate.
That's called Steins Gate.
But in this game...
Oh my gosh, I love Steins Gate.
I better go see how she's doing.
I'm going ghost!
Oh, whose bag is this?
Mr. Officer, are you coming back?
Wait, how am I gonna get over there?
Check on how she's doing...
Oh wait!
I can check with the umbrella.
That's why the umbrella is there.
Through the phone.
Yeah!
I already thought of it before you.
Was that light on before?
Wait.
Here.
There.
Oh, this way.
Well...
It looks like congratulations are in order.
Oh, sorry.
You erased yet another death.
Well, aren't we so clever.
I know.
But I haven't gotten any further in solving my own mystery, though.
But that woman holds the key.
Don't forget that.
Lynn, huh?
Now that she's alive again...
She's probably still being detained in the Supers office.
She won't be able to pursue her case without the freedom to move around.
I'd better go back to the Supers office to see her.
That sounds like a good idea.
Beep boop.
The Supers office.
Actually, you guys, I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I said I was going to go earlier.
But now I actually have to go.
I have to go to the little ghosties room.
Give me one minute.
I'm also gonna get some more tea.
Or coffee.
One or the other.
I'll be right back.
You can enjoy this sick soundtrack while I get more drink.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god.
While I was getting my coffee, a package that I was waiting for came.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get some scissors.
I was waiting for this because...
Ah!
I got...
Stuff for my back.
Ouch!
I got...
This is the thing for me to try later.
For my neck.
I got two things for my neck.
But this one I lay on.
This one's heavy because it's cat food.
Hold on.
I got...
Yeah, stuff for my spine.
Can't be.
Oh.
Wait.
Yippee!
Okay, cat food!
Thank goodness I was running out of cat food.
Yeah!
Stuff!
I'm good.
Oh my god.
Lumbar support.
I feel like such an old person.
Oh.
Okay, there we go.
Umm...
I'm gonna open it.
I'm gonna put it on...
Wait.
Can I put it on right now?
Will it be too difficult to put on?
Also, I realized I didn't have any creamer either for my coffee.
So, it's just coffee and...
Milk.
Oh, gosh.
Grandma mint.
It's just because I have a...
I always get pinched nerves in my arm... and in my... I have sciatica.
That's a pinched nerve in your... in your... butt.
So... I'm home!
This product can cause burns.
55 or older.
Your risk of burning increases as you age.
Do not wear while sleeping.
Check skin frequently during use.
Okay.
Do not use for more than 8 hours.
Actually that works perfect because...
You will burn as you age.
I'm in my 30s.
I just bought an adjustable bed.
Base for back pain.
Embrace it.
Let's go!
Hey, there's nothing wrong with getting something for comfort, you know?
And Draco thanks for the 10 gifted!
Okay.
How do I put this on?
Uh...
Heat cells.
Okay.
Guys, I'm gonna feel the deep penetrating relief.
Wait, which way do I put it on?
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
I think I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna feel the deep penetrating relief that it says.
Clinically proven to relax tight muscles and enhance flexibility and mobility.
Why do I sound like such an old person?
Oh my gosh.
You don't have to say it like that.
Okay, I gotta put it on...
My neck.
I don't feel anything yet.
I'm so glad that this came.
I need the relief.
It's so much pain, you guys.
Okay, I'm so sorry about that.
Alright.
Alright, we're good to go.
Let's go to the super's office.
The age of 3000 isn't a myth.
Hag love!
Woohoo!
Deep penetrating relief.
I decided to go back to the office where Lin was being detained.
With her changed fate, her story was sure to change too.
And maybe that would lead us in some new direction.
Hags are love.
Hags are life.
This is the hag life, you guys.
Have a great summer and also...
Have a... have a... healthy...
Have a pain-free summer.
With neck pain therapy.
Deep penetrating relief.
Yeah.
Now that Lin is alive again, I wonder what she's doing.
She said she was investigating...
Oh my god.
Investigating an important case tonight.
Could that case be connected to me in any way?
Hap... hap...
Ghost hag arc begins.
Oh!
We cleared the challenge.
I'm still so curious what's going on in that guy's basement though.
Listen to the music.
Yeah.
Continue.
If you sleep on your side like I do, I had the same symptoms, tight muscles on the shoulder, neck with bonus tension headaches.
Solved it all by sleeping with a pillow between the knees.
I can... I try.
I seriously cannot sleep with a pillow between my knees.
It drives me insane.
I move around too much in my sleep, I think.
I had one before.
Hag life is either be warm forever or die.
Also, I can't...
Um...
I... I... I'm such a particular sleeper.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So I...
Can't have so much pressure on top of me.
So like...
When... um...
When...
When I have a pillow in between my knees...
It makes it so that the sheets are too tight and it feels like it's...
I'm not claustrophobic, but only...
Only... only when I sleep do I feel claustrophobic.
Because if I can't move around at...
At will, then I feel like I'm gonna die.
But...
But, um...
Dakimakuras exist for a reason.
No!
I can't use a dak...
I only look at dakimakura.
I don't know.
I'm so, so particular.
But at the same time, I have to sleep with all of my arms and legs and everything underneath a big heavy comforter.
Which makes no sense considering...
Considering...
How did you sleep in Japan with their comforters?
I was fine.
It's so weird.
I love my comforter.
Me too!
Oh my gosh, I felt so seen...
Um...
The other day.
Because like, you know how comforters in like...
When you see the pictures of them, they're so billowy and puffy and you're just like...
Oh my gosh!
This looks like the fluffiest ever comforter ever!
And then when you get it, it's like...
Flat and terrible and it feels like there's only five down feathers in it and you're like...
What happened?
I've been...
I've been scammed!
But I found out that there's like a thing that you have to get to make them look fluffy.
I can't remember what it's called though.
Hoodwinked!
Hug your snake ducky when you get it.
Oh, I am.
I am.
Duvet cover?
It might be that.
There was a different name too though.
Anyway.
When Lin lost her life for the second time, she was being detained on suspicion of my murder.
But I saved her, hoping to solve my own mystery.
Living creatures can choose to live their lives in one of two ways.
They can either submit to their fate or they can try to change it.
Lin is definitely in the second camp.
Well, I mean...
She's only trying to change it because you brought her back.
It's you trying to change it.
Just Google fluffing.
Is that what it is?
No, I don't think so.
It's a different word.
As soon as I got back to the junkyard superintendent's office, this fact was really brought home to me.
What is fluffing?
Do not Google that.
Wait, what is that?
Foo!
You...
We told you not to let the suspect out of...
What is fluffing?
Not stream safe?
I'm Googling it.
Don't do it, apparently...
No, Phil, no!
Don't look, Minto.
I'm not going to look it up because I'm scared.
I'm actually...
I have no idea.
Preparation for a certain job.
What?
Fluffing?
What kind of a job would have you prepare for something that would be called fluffing?
Does it have to do anything with being fluffy?
Like...
Like, you know how some bigger people say I'm not fat and fluffy?
No.
Oh, okay.
certain video actors.
AB stuff.
Really?
What's related to AB?
You fluff the relief...
What does that mean?
I'm confused...
To keep you ready between shots.
You fluff the relief?
I just don't understand.
Okay, I'm just going to believe you guys.
I don't get it.
Gotta raise the flag before you sit still.
Oh, wait!
I think I get it.
Anyway...
How do you know?
How do you guys know that?
We told you not to let the suspect out of your sight.
My apologies, sir.
But I never thought she would run away.
Oh my god, she just ran.
She booked it.
Lynn is our angel.
I mean, her friend.
I mean, she's like family to us.
Angel, friend, or family.
They all run when they have the chance.
Because we're perverts.
It's okay.
I like that about you guys.
A little bit.
Okay.
Do you have any idea how many years it's been since my wife ran away?
Holy moly!
Feeny, are you okay?
I'm very sorry.
I have no idea, sir.
You'll never make a detective at that rate.
Dang.
Now find Lynn!
Yes!
Yes, sir.
God.
If Inspector Cabanela gets word of this, it's all over.
This poor guy.
I can see why his wife left him.
So our red-headed detective escaped, did she?
But I just barely saved her a few minutes ago.
She's fast.
Wait, but where's the detective?
Cabanela?
I guess I'll look around for leads.
Her notebook, obviously.
Trick time!
Don't touch that dial.
Close.
No, it's gonna open eventually.
Or...
Oh, hold on.
I want to get to that notebook up there.
So we're going to...
Oh, no, wait.
Wrong thing.
My bad.
Here?
If I turn this around...
Will the steam somehow push it up?
I don't know.
Lynn's notebook.
Sad and forgotten.
Sits behind the bookshelves.
Who could...
She had been calling on the phone before she hid it there.
Wish I could find out.
Hmm.
Try square pillow as a side sleeper for...
I've looked into squared pillow.
Right now, I do have...
I do use a specific pillow.
I've always had back problems.
Forever.
Even as a ghost.
Everything is hard.
What's our guy doing over here?
Oh, there's more people!
I can't hear from here.
Better get closer.
Oh, okay.
Is she down here?
What's he saying?
That old pigeon man.
You suppose he is carrying out some sort of research here?
In fact, problems could be bone related.
Yeah.
I have bad...
Well...
I have...
Now, it's like my bad bones transferred into my ghost life.
You know what I mean?
It kind of sucks.
Look at all these precision instruments and complicated devices.
Bad to the bone.
Ba ba ba bad.
Phantom pain.
What are you doing?
Sir, I think this might be how Lynn escaped.
Through here.
Through the poop chute.
She couldn't possibly fit in that tiny little elevator?
I'm sorry.
Oh, I don't know, sir.
Lynn is pretty slim.
Why are you checking her out, huh?
Don't you know that women can make themselves appear slim through fashion?
You think if you had four minutes, you could at least die with better bones?
Oh my gosh.
Four minutes before my death, I just shoved all the magnesium down my throat.
The men found us out.
No.
What do you mean through...
What are you talking about, Edgeworth?
I mean...
Prosecutor Payne.
To this day, I still don't know how much my wife really weighs.
You don't need to know that.
I'm very sorry.
I had no idea, sir.
You'll never make detective at that rate.
This poor guy.
Anyway, where is that old pigeon man?
Oh, hey.
That's him, sir.
He went through the door behind me, sir.
That one right there.
That door.
Yeah.
It won't open.
Apparently, that door leads to the basement, but it's currently locked, sir.
I'm starting to get why his wife left.
These are two different guys.
Time to gotcha.
Don't know the timing again.
This one was sent on 8.22 JST.
A little over ten minutes.
Okay.
Like 15 minutes.
15 minutes.
Not so bad.
These instruments.
They're all very suspicious.
You'd better keep your eye on that old man, too.
Yes, sir.
If it involves a criminal, wouldn't you, like, bash the door down to try and get in there?
You know?
Like...
Okay.
So we have examined these before, but does he say anything different now?
And now that Lin's not here.
It's just a little fragment of rock, a little pigeon guy, a strange taste of wild decor.
Okay, just a little bit.
When is this gonna heat up?
Wait!
I can't...
I can't attach myself to him anymore.
Oh.
I could swear that I just saw this thing move!
Don't tell me.
This must be.
I sensed the tension between me and the detective and I moved to get away from it.
I think the detective... I think... or not the detective.
This guy might be my favorite character.
Unnamed officer.
He's so funny.
I love unnamed officer.
That was an unexpected tangent.
I'll never make detective at this rate.
No!
Have more confidence in yourself!
What I need is some sort of an achievement.
Achievement.
A feather in my cap.
If only I could find a helpful lead that might...
The book!
A helpful and blindingly obvious lead is staring you in the face right now!
There you go.
I swallowed my spit wrong.
This is Lynn's notebook!
If I give this back to her it might spark something between...
Spark something between us?
What do you mean by that?
Isn't she your family detective?
Um...
What do you mean by that?
Didn't you say she's your family?
She's an angel.
No a friend.
A family.
What to do?
This is a very complicated matter.
No, don't let him take your accomplishment.
Don't let him take your accomplishment!
What have you got there?
What?
This?
This is... wait a minute.
Is that...
Yes, sir!
It's Lynn's notebook, sir!
Notebook, eh?
Come to think of it, there was something about that in the report.
Something about her looking at her notebook and making a phone call.
Don't let him take it from you!
This must be it.
This telephone number with the big circle around it.
ViviCore, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Aren't you curious to know who she was calling?
I am.
I really am, sir.
I'd like to know.
Oh.
But I don't have any ulterior motive for wanting to know, though.
No, sir.
This number might be an important lead.
I'd better check it out.
This music is so Phoenix Wright.
Trick time!
When is this gonna go off, I wonder?
I can't examine it yet.
It's still closed.
I'd like to see what's inside, but this guy has a death grip on it.
I can't open it.
I bet this detective never lets his prey escape once he gets a hold of it.
Here we go!
To
whom am I speaking, please?
Yes, hello?
This is a criminal investigation.
We need your cooperation.
Hey, I know that voice.
Is that you, Detective McCaw?
What did I call him?
Detective McCaw?
Oh, is that Officer Bailey?
Detective...
What's up, sir?
You don't usually call this late.
Oh, uh...
Did you get a call from one of our detectives, Lynn, earlier?
From Lynn?
Yes, I did.
She calls every night.
Maybe she senses it's about to happen.
What is about to happen?
Did she say anything special?
No, not really.
Is something wrong?
Ah, well, hold on.
I might be contacting you again if I have any other questions.
Okay.
Trace complete.
To... that place.
I'm going to go file the report down at the station.
I need you to be vigilant here.
Excuse me, Detective, but...
What is it?
I know.
Why would that guy sit in...
He's avoiding the gamer posture, you guys.
Everybody...
That is peak sitting position.
Everybody should know that.
That's how I'm sitting literally right now.
You don't sit like that?
With your booty out?
And your chest pushed forward?
Like this?
Oh, yes.
This is peak performance.
Obviously.
Actually, let's all stretch.
Oh, my arm.
Sorry.
It's the pinched nerve.
What was I saying?
Oh, that notebook.
Would you mind if I gave...
Oh, never mind, sir.
Just stay on your toes.
Grandma Mint, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Trick time.
When is this gonna heat up?
Maybe when we come back.
Maybe I have to wait.
You almost did it.
You did.
Let's go to that new place.
New people.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
The shrimp.
Was that...
What was that call about?
I heard you say Lynn.
Why is it still like that?
I don't really know.
If I had to take a guess, though, I would probably say...
Something's going on with her.
The only place in the world where nothing is going on is inside your brain, Bailey.
Burn.
What is that supposed to mean?
I mean, I know what the words mean.
That's not what I'm asking.
That was my way of expressing indignation.
Putting it in the form of a question.
Sits back so polite.
Is that guy drinking wine?
On the job?
I just hope Lynn's not doing anything crazy.
I'm a fan of hers, you know?
According to my law...
Is she not a real detective?
Is she like an actress?
Is she like an actress playing the role of a detective?
And like...
She's not actually...
She doesn't actually know anything.
Just passed her test recently.
Oh yeah, so true.
According to my log...
Lynn has been calling here nearly every night as of late.
So let's see.
This is the place Lynn took all that risk to call, eh?
But what exactly is this place?
Trick time...
Trick...
Oh.
Haha.
Ah.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
The lever over there.
You see it on the bottom, right?
We can release all the inmates.
Be free.
Bro's posture.
Look at this.
Wow.
Oi.
I didn't know I would need the eye tracker for this stream.
Like, raps on Twitter.
Okay.
I'm so proud of you and you're freaking amazing.
Thank you.
I don't think we can do anything here.
Phew.
Except...
Except get an eyeful.
Hahaha.
Um...
I guess we'll go back.
Oh wait!
Oh!
Just kidding.
I can let the memo loose.
There's a phone over there too.
Oh.
Let's examine this monitor.
The screen shows rows of tiny rooms.
The rooms are really really small, and you can see right into them from the outside.
I suppose the open bars couldn't keep...
Oh, the open bars keep the rooms airy, but I wouldn't want to live in one myself.
I wonder where these little rooms are.
I wonder.
If I let myself go...
Hey, what's this?
Oh that?
I wrote down my duties for the night.
So I wouldn't forget any of them.
You can't keep them in your head.
It's not like you have a ton of duties.
Why do you put them in quotes like that?
After all...
Use a little brain power.
What are you talking about?
Weren't you the one who said nothing?
You guys, it's so Jover when I get 3D.
And I can be able to do that every time I make a mistake in a video game.
It's so over.
I can't wait.
Weren't you the one who just said nothing was going on inside my brain?
Hmm.
Didn't think you'd take it in quite... wait.
Didn't think you'd take it in quite that direction.
What else are you saying?
So let's see this important to-do list of yours.
9.
Take prisoner C-38 to the telephone room.
Yes.
He just made a request to use the phone a little while ago.
9, eh?
That's when Lin usually calls.
The chair spin... yeah.
Well, we can't let her talk to him tonight.
Rules are rules.
Aw, poor Lin.
Sure wish I could comfort her.
That's okay.
I've got it all memorized for you.
Well, it's your duty to guard the telephone room, you know?
Right there.
Just make sure you do your job when the time comes.
These guys are so goofy.
I love it.
He's gonna put up another memo- oh!
Moshi moshi!
Is it Lin?
It's Lin!
Oh.
Spooky music.
Hello?
L-Lin!
I'm sorry.
I don't have much time.
Please let me talk to him.
I'm sorry, detective.
I can't do that tonight.
You can't?
But you always let me talk to him before.
Well, uh, the telephone room is already reserved.
That's why.
Or he's dead.
Dun dun bum bum.
Bum bum bum bum.
Oh.
By the way, is something going on with you tonight?
What?
Why do you ask?
I got a call from one of the other detectives a minute ago asking about you.
Oh, really?
Oh, well, I don't think it's, uh, anything important.
Officer Bailey?
Do you think you could keep this call just between us?
Even if only for tonight?
Well, I, uh...
Oh!
Look at the time!
I gotta go!
I'll call again tomorrow!
Dang.
Didn't even say bye.
He hung up on her.
Mysterious place.
Oh, boy.
Well, I guess I'd better call the detective division.
No!
Snitches!
Don't do it, Officer Bailey.
Don't do it.
Hold on there, Bailey.
What?
Don't tell me you're gonna report that call from Lynn?
What else can I do?
It's my duty.
Just write it down on one of your important to-do lists.
And then I can wad it up for you in three days.
Throw it away!
You mean, you want me to keep quiet about it?
Well, isn't that what she asked you to- Why were you- Why were you eavesdropping on our call, huh?
Well, yes, but...
Tonight is kind of a special case for us.
Can't you make a special exception for my li- What is
up with all these people claiming Lynn?
Lynn!
Lynn does not belong to all of you!
She belongs to me!
I won't let any of you have her!
Hands off!
Oh, no!
No!
Lynn!
Special case, huh?
All right.
You win.
Trick time!
Wait, so...
What is he going to say?
I don't know what they think is special about tonight.
But for me, it's my only night.
Lynn is on the other end of that telephone line.
I'd better hurry.
Yeah, I was going to do his little memo, but...
I guess we'll- I guess we'll go- I guess we'll dial...
To here.
Oww-er.
Oh, my God.
Lynn...
No...
No.
No way.
Oh!
Is it a rock?
Oh...
I was going to say a locked room case, but I said a rock.
Is she dead again?
Lynn!
Oh, why could it have been me instead?
I'm no use as a police officer.
It should have been...
It should have been me!
Not her!
It looks like she's dead.
We'd better not touch her.
Who did this?
Who shot...
Why do you assume it's a shot?
A gunshot, huh?
Why do you assume that, officer?
Hey, excuse me, mister.
Excuse me.
Are you talking to me?
Whoa!
This room...
There aren't any... It is a locked room case!
It is a locked room case!
There aren't any other exits besides this one, are there?
Do you see one?
Well, there's like a hatch below.
And how did...
We must have one of those mysterious locked room murder cases on our hands!
Murder!
One of those cases where the murderer vanishes into thin air in a vacuum!
Just go find a real detective.
It's Umineko, let's go!
I'll keep watch here.
No, there was like a trap door in the middle of the room.
Is this guy not a suspect?
Why are we letting him stay with the body?
Ah, what a terrible turn of events.
So now a locked room murder, eh?
Things never get dull for our redhead.
I know of a certain inspector who might dance around at the thought of a mystery.
Me.
But no mysteries for me.
Not when I can rewind time and talk to the victim herself.
Guess it's time to go back and see the truth behind this murder with my own eyes.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
I'm going ghost!
I'm going lamp!
I'm going girl!
Or goose?
Haha, I died again!
I thought you'd be a little more grave under the circumstances.
Man, she's not caring about her death at all.
She doesn't care.
She's just like, Not when I have you around!
I found a rewind time!
I
died.
I died.
So silly.
How silly of me.
Oh my gosh, I just keep getting murdered.
That's so silly of me.
Yeah, well, this is the third time after all.
It's scary what a girl can get used to, don't you think?
Frankly, the way her mind works is a whole heck of a lot scarier to me.
Just feeling a little guilty.
Feeling a little goofy.
Might die tonight.
So what happened this time?
Who shot you?
I don't know.
Nani?
I'd like to know myself.
Who could have done it?
Who shot me?
Why?
What are you asking me for?
Oh boy.
Guess I'll have to go find out for myself.
Okay.
You just go do that.
Hurry along now.
I get the distinct impression I'm being used here.
Translator note.
Nani means what?
Okay.
Looks like it's time to go back.
Back to four minutes before your death.
Oh, I forgot.
Let's see.
She called.
844.
Lots of fours in this game, huh?
Okay.
She hears something going on.
Oh.
The doctor?
He looks really frightened.
How long has it been since I locked this room up in darkness?
Okay.
He's a weirdo.
I thought, I once thought the truth could be discovered in darkness.
Oh my god, the Matryoshka dolls look so scary!
Maybe it was just that the time wasn't ripe.
Yeah, see there's a little thing in the middle of the floor.
Wait, so it's not only just a locked room case, but it's also dark?
Oh, she's hiding!
Oh my god, she can hide in there!
The guy was so right!
She... oh my god.
That was so smooth!
Oh!
With the power of fashion!
Moshi moshi!
He hung up.
Oh, it's boiling!
Ow!
His behind!
Okay, there's a lot going on here.
There's Henya!
Okay, goes into the dark room.
Tippy toe.
There's a lot of contraptions in here.
Oh!
Uh oh.
Oh no, I don't think you should have done that!
Oh my god.
And it lights that on fire.
And then...
No way!
What?!
Don't just stand there!
It's a booby trap!
That's the truth behind our locked room murder?
Okay, I saw the gun up there and I thought that it would probably be the thing that shot her, but...
That's...
We got home alone for real.
So the murderer was a mechanical murder machine?
Murder machine?
When I came into the room, it was pitch dark, so I turned on the light.
That must have been what set it off.
The murder machine, I mean!
Can you please stop repeating the words murder machine?
That old pigeon guy must have made it.
But why?
What could be the meaning behind this?
He's trying to figure something out!
But he needs the...
He's hiding it.
If someone comes in to steal his research, they're gonna get murdered!
By the murder machine!
Anyway, you'll have to find some way to stop that creepy machine.
Once Cupid fires his arrow, it's all over.
Okay.
Rewind time!
Trick time!
Oh, we're starting from here?
Interesting.
Okay.
Uh, what is it?
You know what, Cecil?
I think this death might be easier to prevent than the others.
Why is that?
You know, because the murderer is mechanical.
She has...
Did I just disconnect?
Am I good?
I'm good?
Oh, okay.
For a second.
Oh.
Hmm.
Strange.
Sorry about that.
I can't manipulate living creatures.
But I can manipulate this machine.
Now I just gotta figure out how to stop it.
When the four minutes ago...
Me turns on the light...
That's when the murder machine is set in motion, apparently.
So, it looks like the key to solving this one is understanding this device.
Which I think we kind of get.
Oh, yes.
Locked up in the room in darkness.
And...
So, that's what we're gonna do.
Okay, let's try the old-school.
We can...
Infiltrate the lamp.
Oh, interesting.
I don't think me going to...
Oh, wait.
But then, no.
There's the motor up top.
We do have to go upstairs.
I think we have to wait for the guy to...
To call.
And then we go through, right?
Right?
Oh, the telephone isn't working.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Because there was the motor up top.
So we'll wait for it to ring.
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
And he slides down.
All cool, time is passing.
Okay.
Is this the superintendent?
I'm so glad.
I thought I was all alone.
Go there.
Okay.
Okay, he hung up.
Trick time!
Okay, maybe we stop this from going off on your butt.
Oh!
And then you're gonna move it down here?
Oh, this poor guy!
This is the Shinji pose for real.
Oh my gosh, Lin ran away.
The detectives yelled at me.
The old pigeon man ignored me.
Oh no, he's never going to become a detective at this rate.
And then the kettle nearly scared me to death.
My life is in complete shambles!
That's gratitude for you.
We were just trying to warn him with the kettle whistle.
Would he have preferred getting scalded by the steam?
Well, at least his fate was changed a bit.
Yeah, we didn't burn his butt.
That's good anyway.
The fate has been changed for real!
Okay, so the ball.
Okay.
How did it go again?
The present...
The thing started spinning.
The fan started spinning, lifting the present.
And the ball spun over...
I can't tell what everything is because it's hard to see.
Okay, I'm gonna have to...
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm gonna have to be flung to somewhere.
I have to be flung wherever.
I have to...
Okay, hold on.
I'm the toolbox!
Open!
Okay, we went the wrong way.
Nice.
And...
Move the hoist!
I don't know what this does.
Oh no!
Oh no no no!
Oh my god.
Wait!
Oh, I messed up!
Maybe.
What did the bowling ball even do before?
Actually, I have no idea.
I missed it.
Yeah, I think I did.
Oopsie!
That's okay.
We can go from when the fate was changed.
The key to this murder machine is that cheeky little cupid who fires the arrow.
But we were close.
We were so close.
We were close.
Very tight timing.
Yeah.
But wait a minute.
That swinging shovel.
Yes!
I wonder if that can be used as a weapon somehow against our cupid.
Guess I'd better rewind.
Yes.
After the fate change.
Okay.
This trick took me a long time when I first played it.
Hmm.
I think we're...
It's not so bad.
Maybe.
I hope not.
We'll see.
Okay.
Here we go.
Do I need to...
What do I do with this though?
I don't remember if the...
Did the shovel like fling into the air really fast?
Yeah.
No.
Spoil.
No hints.
No hints, no hints.
No hints, everybody.
No hints.
Oh God.
I would do timing...
Oh no.
I didn't.
I just...
Okay.
Trying to look at everything that I can posses.
Hmm.
Timing is everything.
Hm.
Oh...
Huh?
Yeah, Lynn's gonna just keep getting blasted, man.
Think about the timing as well.
Yeah.
That's true.
Cookmint, I believe you!
Sometimes it just takes me a second, okay?
Some people said it took them a long time to get stuff.
What is that thing behind the box?
I don't even know what that is.
The murder machine has started!
If the whole thing plays out, that gun will go off before that happens.
I need to use my ghost tricks.
There must be some way to disrupt this domino effect.
I just have to find it.
Oh, wait!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think... I think when the ball...
When the ball lands, I have to...
Time the ball landing to the shovel falling so it will...
So it will go... It will swing it up, I think.
Is what I have to do.
Oh my god.
Maybe now?
That was pretty good just now.
Maybe if we were on a... on a putting green.
With a swing like that, maybe we could put it to use here.
Good thinking.
I was just... I just might be able to use this trick somehow.
If I could change the path the ball takes.
Change... Okay.
Change the path the ball takes.
That's great and all, but it looks like we're all out of time this round.
Is it this?
What does this go to?
Oh, I guess I'll never know.
Okay.
We got this.
After the fight change.
Okay.
But what does the...
I still don't know what that thing down there is.
And would this be...
Wait, how would we change the direction?
How would we change the direction?
Why doesn't Lynn dodge it?
Is she stupid?
Yeah.
Maybe a little.
Oh, I can't reach it.
Can I reach here?
I don't know if this does anything, but I'm gonna try it.
Here we go.
Then here.
And...
I don't know if this will do anything.
Open!
Oh, gosh.
No, that didn't do anything.
How do I change it?
Um...
I don't know if it will let me go back into the ball when I push it.
But maybe.
Let's see.
Ride the ball after it's hit.
That's what I'm gonna see if I can do.
I don't...
I don't know if it will let me...
If it counts as a cutscene or if it will let me ghost trick a little bit.
I have no idea.
We'll see.
Oh, before it falls.
No, but I have to...
I have to open the toolbox.
Oh, but you mean like...
Wait.
Maybe like with the most tightest of timings.
Oh, no.
It wouldn't let me ghost trick.
No.
Oh, no.
It won't let me.
No.
Yeah,
it's a cutscene.
This one's tricky.
This one's kinda tricky.
This box...
I don't know how to reach it.
Unless...
Okay, hold on.
Let me try something.
Unless when the ball is on the table, I can go to it.
And then it does whatever it does.
I'm not sure what it does.
But it might do something.
Oh, no.
It's just a toy cake.
Are you serious?
Wait.
Door.
There we go.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I thought it just set everything on fire.
What just happened?
Looks like your future just got a whole lot rose... rose-ier.
Happy birthday!
Your death has been erased.
I...
Thank you.
You kept your promise, didn't you, Sissel?
I...
My promise.
And now she can escape through the trapdoor.
You said I'd see you again if I died.
I don't remember making any promises.
It's all for my own benefit, anyway.
Fate averted!
What could this room be all about?
I can't imagine.
Those things that went off at the end.
Those were party poppers.
Oh, no.
Did they hear them?
Did they hear the potty pop...
Potty is the...
No!
The party poppers!
I can't imagine.
I have no recollection of what they are, but that's no surprise.
I said it with an accent, you guys.
The party poppers.
I just said it with an accent.
I didn't say party poppers.
I said the potty poppers.
It's the party poppers.
The party poppers.
The gun going off.
It seems familiar, somehow.
I'll leave that part of the puzzle to you.
I have my own puzzle to figure out.
Well, shall we go back?
No saving this one, boss!
What do you mean?
Okay, now you can leave.
Or you can investigate what's going on in here.
Cecil, are you there?
Oh, she remembers me.
Lin is talking to me?
Yes.
If you're there, could you say something?
If you're not there... I guess I'm just a weird girl who talks to herself.
She remembers!
Well, you are kind of a weird girl.
Whether you talk to yourself or not.
Trick time!
What do we say?
Talk?
Wait...
You are here!
I knew it!
I just had that feeling.
Wait, what?
Shame on you for stepping foot into a girl's head uninvited.
Wait a minute.
Poshmint, my beloved.
Don't give me that a ghost doesn't have feet bit.
I have feet.
Sometimes.
It's just a figure of speech.
Depends on how much energy I have.
How much ghostly energy I have, you know?
Yeah, but she did invite him.
I'm so true.
Hey, did I say anything?
There!
That tone!
It's that tone of yours that makes me mad!
Oh, sorry.
She has an accent now.
So did you have something particular you wanted to say to me?
Hmm... in British.
I just thought I'd share some information with you.
I'm investigating a case right now.
A murder case.
And I'm doing it alone.
A murder case?
All by yourself?
Yes, well, that's because the case was closed a long time ago.
The culprit is already behind bars.
Forgotten by the world.
I think it's the lamp.
I think it's the lamp making amends.
So why are you lo- Or the person that was murdered by the lamp.
I mean, the guy behind bars.
So why are you looking into it then?
Because I think the person's innocent.
That's why.
There's something strange behind the case.
Some big mystery.
I firmly believe that.
So anyway, I'll- I finally have my memory back.
I'm not at liberty to tell you about the case.
But if there's any- I'm so sorry if you're British by the way.
Because you're British.
And also because I'm probably really butchering this accent.
But if there's anything else you want to know, I'll try to answer what I can.
We deserve it.
No!
Played by Emma Watson.
That's who I'm channeling.
Lin is my only lead.
I would like to ask her about a few things.
About the girl with the bow.
Oh yeah!
What about about the dog?
What?
You have your life and your memory back now.
So let me ask you again.
Who shot me tonight?
Yeah, I thought that might be the first thing on your mind.
What else would it be?
There's a good chance I was shot while I was with you after all.
I'm afraid my memory just isn't clear on that part.
Not clear?
I met with you tonight.
And then you fell down right in front of me.
I think I remember seeing that part.
I'm pretty sure you were shot.
Maybe from somewhere far away.
Two steps ahead!
So you didn't see the culprit.
I'm sorry.
I wish I could be of more help.
But I know I wasn't the one who shot you.
Your colleagues seem to think you're a suspect though.
I wanted the information you had for me.
So why would I shoot you before I got it?
So true.
Information, huh?
I wonder what info I had for her.
It's me.
I was the murderer.
About the dog.
Oh, dang.
About the girl with the bow.
By the way, I see you have a little roommate.
Camilla?
How do you know about her?
There was a tiny incident at your apartment a little while ago.
An incident?
What kind of incident?
What happened?
Is Camilla all right?
She's fine.
Thanks to her loyal little friend...
Missile!
Yeah!
It's a good boy, Missile!
Missile!
Although I did have a little trouble bringing him back to life.
Oh my!
Oh, it's horrible!
Oh my god!
Bloody hell!
What in the world is going on?
Why would anybody target to hurt Camilla and Missile?
You're being targeted by a certain organization.
Missile Mansion!
Yeah!
What?
I saw them.
The people who were calling you their target.
So I'm a suspect and a target.
Could this night possibly get any worse?
This sounds pretty rough.
Are you sure you'll be okay on your own?
English Mint is killing me.
Sorry.
Huh?
You know what they say.
When it rains, it pours.
Isn't it time you admitted you need me?
Need my powers?
I'm sorry.
I can't cooperate with you.
Yes, you saved my life tonight three times!
I'm completely grateful for that.
But as a detective, I still can't trust you.
That's too bad.
And about the information.
And the dog.
So I had some important information that you wanted, huh?
I think... I feel like you could trust me even more because I have no memory.
Right?
Levios saw.
That's right.
You called the station yesterday.
And you asked to talk to me.
You told me you had an important lead on the case I was working on.
Important lead, eh?
You said you wanted to meet me and talk to me directly.
Tonight.
At the junkyard.
Important.
And you fell for it?
Even given how fishy it sounds?
You're the last person I want to hear that from, you know?
But I just couldn't let it go.
No matter how shady it seemed.
I'm walking here.
That's because I'm running out of time.
Oh my god.
Are they gonna kill that guy in the jail?
Hey, that's right.
You said something was going down tonight.
Is he gonna die?
Does that something have to do with the case you're working on?
I'm sorry.
But I can't talk about it.
You stop!
Stop being so mysterious!
Oh boy.
But I guess I understand.
Death sentence, maybe.
Oh wow.
Okay.
Let's stop dilly-dallying here.
So what are you gonna do now?
Run, I guess.
They'll catch me again if I don't get out of here.
What is this accent?
I don't even know anymore.
And I have to get to the restaurant.
I'm worried about Camilla.
Oh yeah, what was it?
The chicken kitchen on Dead End Drive, right?
What about you, Cecil?
What are you going to do?
I'm gonna follow you!
I don't know, to tell you the truth.
You're my only lead.
If you leave...
Yeah, feel guilty.
Feel bad.
I just saved your life three times.
I just realized you and I are in the same boat.
We're both looking for answers tonight, and neither one of us has anybody to help us.
Why do you have an accent again?
Hey, even if you can't cooperate with me, how about if we just agree to use each other?
That's not a bad idea.
You're on.
But can I ask you to do a favor for me, first?
What's that?
I need you to sneak into a certain place for me.
A prison, to be exact.
The prison!
Prison!
That's the place I was calling from the office upstairs.
I want you to go find out a certain prisoner's work schedule for tomorrow.
Uh-oh.
I don't know.
I don't like the sound of this.
Work schedule?
For a prisoner?
Yes.
The prisoners are given different job details every day.
Each prisoner's schedule for the next day is written on a small blackboard in his cell.
So just go check out a certain prisoner's blackboard, huh?
Okay.
His prisoner number is D99.
Do.
If you do that for me, I'll cooperate with you.
Okay.
You're on.
Here.
Let me give you the Chicken Kitchen's telephone number.
All right.
Easy.
Chicken Kitchen.
Oh.
Where are we now?
Smell you later.
See ya.
But don't die again.
If you can help it.
Oh, we're in the sewer.
Oh.
Lamp!
He's like, yippee!
It looks like I hold the key to the case Lin is investigating.
And she holds the key to solving the mystery of me.
So we've started up a strange relationship of cooperation.
Lin gave me an assignment.
My task is to go check out tomorrow's work schedule for prisoner D99.
I'd better get to the prison.
Yippee!
But in grandpa voice.
I love this little contraption he has going on in here.
But what is he researching?
It's the stuff with the rocks, right?
There's so many parts of this game.
I'm not really cooking much.
I don't really cook much in games.
I kind of just like to...
To...
Be surprised, you know?
Oh, it's 9.03 PM!
Secret Seeker, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Yeah, just go with the flow.
Yeah.
Lost memories of self.
A forgotten murder case.
A dead guy and a detective joined forces to find out the truth behind them both.
Everything is so disjointed at the moment anyway.
Yeah, true.
The detective assigned the dead guy a task.
To sneak into the prison and find out a certain prisoner's schedule for tomorrow.
I like this music here.
What should I care?
I don't have a schedule for tomorrow.
That's how I'm feeling about it at the moment.
Trick time!
Alright, let's get back to a phone here.
That's why this moves.
Sneaky.
Sneaky, sneaky.
Grandpa.
Our detective!
Oh my god.
It's all over.
It's all over for me.
Lin.
Sweet, cute Lin who shines as bright as the sun.
Ran away from... ran away on me.
And then those detectives matching bookends blue and green yelled at me.
Forget all about that.
Now you listen to me, kid.
Yes.
You are bright as the sun, Lin.
Probably doesn't even know you exist.
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
This is like... your streamer doesn't even know you exist.
No!
One second.
And those detectives will probably yell at you your whole life.
Oh my god.
Getting too real.
Never mind fretting about every little setback.
Enjoy your life.
Get what you can out of it.
Mister.
Would you mind just leaving me alone?
Aww.
Shoot.
Sorry.
I just put some chapstick on.
But I thought it was emptier than it really was and it just splat all over my lips.
Now it's all over my finger.
My lips are gonna be the most hydrated ever.
Do we even exist-ment?
Who are you?
Just kidding.
Who are you guys?
Mint doesn't even know who I am.
Who are you?
She forgot about me.
All I'm thinking about is missile.
I wanna know what's in that book so bad.
Time to go to the prison.
Oh.
We can go to the chicken kitchen.
No, but we have a job to do.
Wait.
Oh, here.
Uniformed.
No.
There we go.
Do you think missile will be at the chicken kitchen?
Mint would never read this.
What did that say?
So how are the preparations coming along?
I think they're taking care of them right now.
Yeah?
Man, I'm not looking forward to this.
That kind of surprises me.
Coming from you.
I didn't know you thought about such things.
By the way, that was me being sarcastic.
Just in case you didn't catch that.
Check the apartment for missile.
No missile left the apartment.
Missile busted down the door and bolted away, didn't it?
Two more hours.
And then it's time.
Oh my god.
We're gonna go check their jail cell and it's gonna say nothing on their work.
It's gonna say, work for tomorrow.
Death.
Oh my god!
I guess we should just get back to work.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Oh my gosh, I don't wanna do death tomorrow.
The atmosphere sure seems tense.
I guess I'll just get back to my work as well.
Find out a certain prisoner's work schedule for tomorrow.
Blah, blah, blah.
Each prisoner's schedule for the next day is written on a blackboard in a cell.
D99, everybody.
Alrighty then.
How do I get to these cells?
I'd better try to get some information here first.
Trick time!
We have this memo and this memo.
And the monitors.
Maybe now that we know what's going on on the monitor, we can check it.
Tiny rooms, really small.
Okay.
No, we've read that before.
What's this memo?
Oh no, not let loose!
I like the way he holds it.
What is it?
Hey, Bailey.
Try pinning up your memos a little better next time.
Let me see this thing.
Inspection prisoner C-74.
Oh, it's almost time for that.
I'd better prepare.
Prisoner C-74, eh?
What did that big whale do?
I can't believe you could be thrown in jail for a gacha addiction.
That's kind of messed up.
You don't know about the Metro Police Department's siege case?
Metro who what?
C-74 barricaded himself into the Metro Police Department and took siege of the place.
He even pointed a huge flamethrower at the chief commissioner.
Damn!
C-74!
Why the heck did he do all that?
That's what the detectives who surrounded him asked too.
What are your demands, they asked.
And...
Oh my god, he said...
More free pulls!
The gacha... the rate up is a lie!
The guy looked confused, thought about it for a while and said...
Bring me five servings of curry and rice.
On the double.
Curry and rice?
That's it?
Yeah.
Unfortunately, no.
After he was done eating, he torched the commissioner's office with the flamethrower.
Torched it good.
Important documents and the commissioner's mustache were destroyed by the flames.
Not the mustache!
Comrade!
What the heck did he do all that for?
Because the curry was too spicy, he said.
The Furies.
This is the Furies' origin story.
It was too spicy and I just lost it, he said.
Seriously?
The case sent shockwaves throughout the country.
But it doesn't make any sense in the first place.
How did a huge armed guy make it all the way into the commissioner's office alone?
It's a complete mystery.
What?
Why don't they just ask C-74 himself?
Maybe they did, but they didn't...
They hadn't released anything about it.
With his huge arms.
Apparently, it's all a matter of national secrecy.
Huh.
Interesting.
Why does he do that?
Why don't you quit throwing my important duty memos away?
Okay.
Is he going to put another one up on the board?
Is this the same one as before?
I was hoping that I could possess the paper ball when he threw it so I could check the second monitor, but it won't let me.
Hey, Bailey.
I think this guy has a southern accent.
What's the matter?
You can't even pin up a memo properly?
Let me see this thing.
Take prisoner C-38 to the telephone room.
Yes, he just made a request to use the phone a little worse.
A while ago.
You already told me that earlier.
C-38, eh?
You can move before you press the bubble.
Oh, I can?
In Japan, a death row's inmate execution date is not revealed until the day of.
I think that's why Lin was asking is tomorrow the day.
Oh.
I didn't know that.
Interesting.
But see, that's what I think.
He also was on death row.
I think so.
Oh.
What did that punk do anyway?
You never heard the story about the secret rendezvous case?
Ooh la la.
Secret who what?
C-38 was a singer in a band.
His group was playing a concert that was being broadcast all over the country live.
And right in the middle of their encore, there was a huge incident.
A huge incident?
What was it?
A murder or something?
In a way, it was even worse than a murder.
Because it had to do with national secrets.
Oh my gosh, he said the launch codes in a song.
25473.
118.
Add a 2.
Square root of 81.
555 and your mom's birthday.
That is the launch codes.
To the missiles.
And to cause all the doom.
I'm gonna get thrown in jail.
Huh?
National secrets?
A rock band?
I'm lost.
Before the stream cuts out.
I didn't even say the best part.
The best part.
That's the launch codes.
If you figured it out.
You're a genius.
And then you can take over the world.
Yeah!
So?
I gave you the key, everybody.
You just gotta go and lock the lock.
The song that they were doing was called Secret Rendezvous.
But the lyrics CS38 was singing were completely different from usual.
So how is that a huge incident?
Oh my god, deep throat.
Because the new...
Oh, sorry.
The new lyrics expose all the nation's dark steamy secrets.
Does he mean steamy?
That was clever.
What?
The launch code?
Yeah.
The last part's a doozy, isn't it?
Budget misappropriations.
Foreign economic strategies.
Illicit dealings.
Everything.
See me is a word?
Oh, it is.
First Mint blows the whistle on Boeing.
Then she reveals launch codes.
She's a rebel.
Mint played us like a damn fiddle.
What are you talking about?
He was caught red-handed in the act of leaking national secrets.
You are so silly, Peter.
Thanks for the pink.
Seriously?
The case sent shockwaves throughout the country.
But it doesn't make any sense.
In the first place, how would a rock singer know any top-secret information?
It's a complete mis...
Oh my gosh, there's so many mysteries here.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Why don't they just ask C-38 himself?
Maybe they did, but they haven't released anything about it.
Apparently, it's all a matter of national secrecy.
She's gonna put up more memos though, right?
Ah!
Why did you quit throwing my important duty memos away?
Okay.
Okay, here's a new one.
Here's a new one.
Hey,
Bailey.
Okay, here.
I can ghost.
I can operate the emergency switch.
That's pretty impressive.
Let me see this thing.
Bring dinner to prisoner D99!
Uh-oh.
Is it his final meal?
The chief is preparing it for him right now.
Uh-oh, it's his final meal.
Ooh, how fancy.
That's why they're preparing it.
D99, eh?
Even I know about this one.
Yeah?
Such a sad case.
Hard for us too.
He shot his wife, didn't he?
Right in front of a family member.
The music.
It's just awful.
Why in the world did he do it?
What would be your final meal?
I don't remember what my final meal was.
I don't know what I ate last before I died.
Hmm.
Maybe like, um, omurice or something.
Why would he do something like that, of all people?
The mode of everything?
God, these detectives suck.
They can't figure out anything.
Everything's a complete mystery.
It's just ridiculous.
It doesn't make sense that you would do anything like that.
I don't know the details, but apparently this case is a matter of national secrecy as well.
I don't get it.
None of it makes any sense.
You do know what kind of prison this is, don't you?
No?
It's a special prison built for these kinds of special cases.
That D99.
Who knows what he's thinking or hiding behind that beard of his.
I don't like any of it.
I had my money on the exploding pies from Spongebob.
I knew I couldn't take my job seriously without it getting to me.
So the prisoner I'm looking for, D99, was convicted of murder.
Murder.
And he apparently has a beard.
Oh my god.
Would you quit throwing away my duty memos?
Alright.
It's time.
Hi.
Wait, I've heard that sound before.
Oh, it's the rock star.
Oh my god.
Why do they allow him to have a guitar in prison?
It's a stalk sound?
Okay.
I'm like, where have I heard that sound, that door sound before?
Oh, he finished putting up the thing.
It's done.
Uh, emergency!
Oh, that's a lot of guns.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that like a...
Is that like a grenade launcher?
There you go again, fooling around with that thing.
A bazooka?
It wasn't me.
Don't lie.
Oh no, you love to see me jump and prepare for emergency.
Oh yeah, sure.
Way back when I first got this job.
But I've had enough of that now.
Besides, you always react exactly the same.
The emergency switch is probably just loose.
Probably because I fooled around with it too much.
Well, it's for emergencies.
Don't play with it.
Anyway, it wasn't me.
Maybe you ought to get it repaired, huh?
Dang, I'm back!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
For anyone watching the VOD, um, we just had a bit of a hiccup here.
We're back!
Hopefully, we're good.
I just, I just stopped on the night vision goggles and I laughed about it.
And then, and then OBS crashed.
It was the night vision goggles' fault.
I was like, I was like, no way.
Night vision goggles.
Oh, it is a bazooka.
More night vision goggles.
Oh wait, we can check the...
Um...
Okay, anyway, back to business.
Okay, we can't check that monitor, but can we...
Oh, we still can't reach that one either.
Can I operate the bazooka?
No.
Yeah, sorry about that, guys.
Oh, I can go here.
Camera.
Button.
Door.
Let's try pressing this.
Nala!
Oh
wow, that's very tricky timing.
Okay, okay.
Press!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Nice.
So this is the thing that was making that horrible noise a second ago.
Am I still...
Am I back, you guys?
I can't tell.
Refresh if you're having issues.
I can't tell if I'm back.
I think my chat is dead.
Hold on, screen.
I think it's because...
Oh no, chat is all messed up on screen.
Oh, there it is.
I think OBS crashes when it doesn't get a good connection to...
To YouTube.
It should have given us the launch codes.
Yeah, you're so right.
I think maybe I jinxed myself by stopping my own stream earlier.
I mean, I didn't do anything of the sort.
Wait, how long have I been streaming?
Okay, almost 3 hours.
I wanted to go longer.
I'm just nervous about...
Let's just go a little bit longer.
Because I wanted to play so much today.
I want it to go longer today.
We'll see how if it if it acts up again but since it like disconnected earlier too I'm just kind of nervous.
I guess it's a way for this spiky-haired youth to express himself.
Sentiments like I'm hungry or I'm thirsty maybe.
Something primitive like that I bet.
Peace out!
I'm done!
Alright C38, back to your cell.
Hey guard man, how about giving me a little space?
That crazy walk of yours is doing... yours is dangerous man.
A proper walk for a properly led life.
Now let's go.
Yo, no lectures man.
I walk my own path.
My own way to my own music.
I'm going to blame the Patriots.
Me too.
And we're inside the guitar so we get to go into the jail cell.
Where's our beard?
Oh that guy has a beard.
I can't tell if that guy has a beard.
So I finally made it to the cells.
Now to find prisoner D99 and check out his work schedule for tomorrow.
What could Lin possibly want with that information?
This game is the GOAT.
Watching a blind playthrough is a lot of fun.
I wish I can re-experience it for the first time again.
Hope you enjoy.
Thank you.
I always feel that was like I of course feel that way with Metal Gear.
But it's like at the same time I'm so glad that I played it.
If I had never played it then I would never have experienced it once to begin with.
Don't think I can take another second in this stinking pit.
Dang he has all his instruments and everything.
Looks like the guard man is gone.
All this weight in his hands is wiping me out.
Hope this one will finally do it.
Oh my god he's sending the launch codes through code.
Come on sausage head.
What?
This is a lenient prison.
For real.
I was just thinking like they allow basketballs.
They allow... like this guitar is so spiky it should be considered a weapon.
That's pretty cool.
I love it.
I I can't read!
Oh God, I can't read!
I can see that there's some kind of...
But I have absolutely no idea what it means.
I can't read.
If I can't read Prisoner D99's work schedule for tomorrow, what do I do now?
What
is this?
Oh, this telephone.
Looks like it's an internal line only.
It doesn't call outside the prison.
So the only places I can go with this telephone are...
Other phones within the building that I've already possessed.
Oh, nice though.
I can't read.
Oh my gosh, I can't read.
Empty prison.
Looks like there's... I can't tell if the line going down...
What if I just press the emergency button?
An emergency button.
In a prison.
That's gotta be a pretty bad situation.
I'll give it a little try.
Time to cause chaos.
Uh oh.
Oh, he just told him, no, no, no!
Where do I...
Go from here?
I think I have to cause that and then go through the note, maybe?
Hmm...
What is this?
Oh, I can play the drum!
Hey, quit that racket!
This music almost sounds like Pokemon, like...
Battle music, doesn't it?
Oh wait, I think through here I can see what's going on.
It won't let me move around.
That's kinda weird.
It really lets me see what's going on on the screen.
But I'm trying to move and it won't let me move.
Oh!
They moved him!
Wait a second.
Oh...
Well, that's not our guy anyway, right?
Oh, and also this counts as a cutscene.
Go, go, go!
What's going on?
Does this count as a beard?
This guy has a beard?
Both of them have a beard.
Why is this guy a baby?
Why does this guy have the large...
What is this guy?
Ooh!
His head is so wobbly.
I don't think I...
Oh my god!
Prison break!
This guy
was accidentally attached to the thing and I didn't realize.
By the looks of him...
That must be the curry lover from the police department's siege case.
But never mind that.
Where did he go?
What is going on in this cell?
There's a little blackboard here too.
Just to be safe.
Maybe I'd better check the curry lover's schedule for tomorrow too.
But I can't read.
You solved it by accident?
Well, I knew what I had to do but I didn't realize I was...
I didn't realize I was...
Possessing the note.
I still can't read.
But I'd better go check out prisoner D99's cell anyway.
Maybe I can find some kind of information that might help Lin out.
Besides, I want to see what this prisoner Lin is investigating looks like.
Okay.
Oh, I can't get over there.
Uh oh.
Ring-a-ling!
Come back mister!
Come back!
His spoon.
Phew!
Oh, nice.
Thank you, sir.
Same thing here.
It doesn't call outside.
Other phones within the building that I've already possessed.
Well, we've possessed this one now, so we're good.
Okay, here we are.
Oh, he's an artiste.
Oh, hmm.
With a...
What is that on the wall?
What a strange cell.
And the prisoner inside it...
He seems to be enjoying himself.
Sorry, I'm invading your private time.
This is the last cell in this area.
So that means that this man humming to himself must be prisoner D99.
According to what the guards say.
Oh, yeah.
Recap.
He shot his wife in front of a family member.
What in the world really happened?
And why is Lin so concerned about this prisoner?
I don't know the answers and I guess there's no need for me to know.
I have only one objective.
And that's to find out what this painter's work schedule is for tomorrow.
Trick time!
Picture frame.
Okay, open that up.
Ooh.
What's it?
I wonder if these are his family.
Oh my gosh, that's kind of gruesome though.
Oh my god.
It's my wife and a giraffe.
My children.
My child is a giraffe.
Why is the left picture a giraffe?
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I wonder if these are of his family.
This one looks like a young woman holding a baby.
You
guys see the giraffe?
You guys see the giraffe, right?
Oh, I know.
Oh, I can see it?
Okay.
Ooh.
Their faces have been blotted out with black paint.
Oh, so the baby is definitely Lin, right?
Did he do it out of hatred or some other emotion?
Thankfully, that's not something I need to know right now.
She definitely became a detective to figure out her dad's situation.
A newspaper article has been cut out and framed.
Unfortunately, I can't read it.
Hahaha.
I'm stupid.
I'm dumb.
I'm so dumb.
It's probably about D99's case.
Man murders wife or something like that.
Why would you frame that though?
There's a picture of the alleged culprit in the article.
Yep.
It's this prisoner.
All right.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
The work schedule for tomorrow of prisoner D99.
It's going to be...
Okay.
The reason we don't need this article is because...
We don't need to know how to read is because it's going to be empty.
Oh my gosh.
If we don't need to know, it's going to be empty.
It's going to be empty.
The information Lin's been looking for should be written on this blackboard.
Unfortunately, I've lost the ability to read.
But here I am anyway.
The least I can do is take a look.
Huh?
What could this mean?
There's nothing written on the board.
Oh no.
Oh my God.
No work tomorrow.
Oh gosh.
He has death tomorrow.
I think something was written on the blackboard.
I think something was written on the blackboards of the other prisoners.
But this blackboard is as clean and blank as the day it was hung there.
I knew it.
So I have the answer Lin was looking for.
Tomorrow's work schedule for prisoner D99.
D99 is...
Nothing.
Would this information mean anything to her?
It's not up to me to know or care.
That's how I feel at the moment anyway.
And then they're cooking his final meal.
I'm jealous.
Oh my gosh.
Mister.
Not being able to read.
I was wondering how this was going to turn out.
Some things in this world can be read even if no one can...
Even if one can't read.
No one can read.
Prisoner D99's work schedule for tomorrow is blank.
I'd better get this important information to Lin as fast as I can.
Close.
Dinner.
Quite a feast tonight I see.
He's huge.
He's the literal chat meme.
This guy.
Oh my gosh.
This guy is the chat meme.
He's huge.
He cuts out of the frame.
And I'm absolutely crazy about this chicken.
Oh, he's smiling.
It's too bad it's all cold and hard though.
I'd say it's been about two hours since it was cooked, judging from the way it feels.
D99?
I know it's kind of pointless to ask now.
But just the same.
I still want to know.
Why did you do it?
I agree, it's pointless to ask now.
My case is colder than this chicken and has been forgotten by everybody.
Myself included.
Detective Zhao?
He was a detective!
I'm sorry.
Now then, let me eat in peace before it gets too cold to cut.
Why did they take so long to serve him his dinner?
Oh, that is art.
There's one more thing I've been wondering for a long time.
What's that?
Is it about Lin?
Your daughter?
Oh, who was the man in that painting?
Oh, this?
It's the culprit.
Well, being in prison like this, you start to forget faces, you know?
So I paint the faces that I don't want to forget.
And this is the last of those faces.
Could you leave me alone for a bit?
Wait!
What?
It's me!
Let a man eat.
Eat in peace.
Okay, sure.
Sorry to bother you.
We must have...
Did we work together?
What's going on?
Wait.
Our hair is so similar.
I don't know.
Are we brothers?
What's going on?
Partners?
Yeah, like, were we detective partners?
Were we...
I don't think we were detective partners, though.
Because they would have known we were detectives together.
I don't know.
I think we were brothers!
What in the world?
What in the world could this mean?
Why is there a painting of me in this man's cell?
Oh my God.
Who exactly is this prisoner?
The man whose case Lin is investigating is painting a picture of me in a cell.
If only he could read.
I have to go see Lin fast.
Not for her sake.
For mine.
To solve this mystery of me.
Eat the chicken.
Napkin.
Bottle.
That's me.
Alright.
We know we can get to her by going through the phone.
Doesn't connect to the outside.
And I've got questions I want to ask Lin.
Yeah.
We go to the office.
Got to get to a place that has an external line and fast.
Yeah.
I know.
The guard room.
Moshi moshi.
This is headquarters.
What's the status over there?
Oh, chief.
It's you.
They're making preparations now.
No problem, sir.
How much longer, then?
One more hour, sir.
I see.
Can't really...
One more hour?
Oh, one more thing.
What is it, Columbo?
Inspector Cabanela wishes to speak to you.
I think Cabanela is the guy who's done everything.
I think it's him.
I think he's going to do a switch on us.
Evening.
Cabanela here.
How are you boys doing?
Hubba hubba.
Inspector Cabanela.
Fine, sir.
You got another little call tonight, didn't you?
From my baby.
Oh, from Lin?
Uh, well, yes...
No!
Bailey!
You weren't supposed to snitch.
Chief has his dogs out.
What do you mean?
Did my girl have anything interesting to say?
Uh, not especially.
She hung up almost immediately.
I see.
Next time she gives you a buzz, you're going to have to tell her.
Be sure to let me know right away.
That's a good fellow.
Yes, sir.
You try to cover it up and I'm sure you'll regret it very much.
Very much.
Thank you very much.
Yes, sir.
I'll call you right away, sir.
Immediately.
I can kind of see...
I can catch glimpses of his feet.
Don't forget, she's a fugitive after all.
Yes, sir.
Carry on then.
I might pop in a little later.
Yes, sir.
Looking forward to seeing you, sir.
Oh my god, his feet.
Yeah, his shoes are off.
Why?
Why did you ride her out, you dummy-dumb?
Inspector Cabanela seems to be looking for her, too.
You're Lynn, I mean.
Inspector Cabanela?
What would that Special Investigation Unit want with Lynn?
I don't know.
I guess something about... something happened that we don't know about.
Tonight, of all nights.
He really is barefoot.
Let's put it on the feet wiki.
No!
Do you guys mind if I grab some more water real quick?
I drank all my coffee.
I just want some hot water for my throat.
And I'm gonna get a little snack.
But it'll be fast.
Just give me like one minute.
One minute to go get some drink.
I'll be right back.
I'm so sorry for taking two breaks.
I'm sorry!
I'm back and I have a guest.
I have a special guest who decided to join me.
Paz!
What you doing in here?
You silly girl!
What are you doing in here, Paz?
I got some...
Oh, they're wet.
Why is it so wet?
That container that's wet.
Why?
I don't know.
It's my cat.
She's here.
Oh!
What are you getting into?
No!
Hold on!
Oh!
No!
I'm so sorry, guys.
I'm so sorry.
One second.
Oh, gosh.
I need to put my food down, but I don't know where to put it.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
We're good.
She really said, venceremos.
Sometimes I know it's like with Meryl, but sometimes I like to be like, you said you'd be a good girl.
A little pause... and we are back.
That's why he calls Lynn his baby.
I think.
You sure about that?
They were such good friends.
How come Inspector Cabanella never came to visit him?
He's the head of a special investigation.
He's a very busy man.
You couldn't be that stylish and a bad guy
Rotting away in a place...
I think this guy does have a southern accent.
Rotting away in a place like this.
Wait, how do I do a southern accent?
And I can't even do anything to help Lynn.
What am I doing with my life?
This new side of you.
It's kind of endearing.
Gosh, are you developing a crush?
Anyway, the thing to do is work at fixing what you can.
Little by little.
Like, for example, your house of cards.
It collapsed, you know.
Can love bloom?
Even in the prison office?
Lynn should be heading for the chicken kitchen now.
Call from the police headquarters intrigues me too.
Hmm...
It's looking pretty obvious right now.
That white suited inspector suspects Lynn.
And she's being considered a fugitive.
This is not good.
I wonder if I should go check in on the chief and the inspector in white too.
I think we should get the information to her first.
Right?
Oh wait, dial.
Dial, dial, dial.
External line.
Oh my gosh, we're getting so many places now.
Is Lynn the only woman in this world?
I know, right?
Besides the roommate, she is the only other girl we've met.
I think.
Oh, and the mom.
That fancy lady.
The chicken kitchen.
This is where that little lady and Lynn are supposed to meet.
But...
I don't see either one of them here.
Oh yeah, and her daughter.
So true, so true.
Guess they haven't shown up yet.
It's been so much time.
What do you mean they haven't shown up?
This music is so funky.
There's someone singing.
In my right ear.
Oh!
Sorry, I'll quiet down.
Yeah.
Pipe down there, mister.
Hello?
I would like some service.
Alright.
I guess we have to go to the other place before...
They're forcing me.
They're forcing me to go to here.
Before we can experience chicken dining.
Fine chicken dining.
Mm-hmm.
In the law.
Oh, his toes!
Preparation seemed to be going smoothly over at the prison.
Eh, Inspector Cabanela?
We were just a little too late.
So close, eh, Inspector?
We still have a little...
A little time left, Chief.
Not much, but some.
We've had Point X surrounded all night.
If he shows up, we nab him.
And we can still make it.
If he shows up...
The real murderer of the wife?
But then why would you even tell that guy that he's gonna die?
Tomorrow.
Unless...
He has nothing on his board because...
He's getting away free!
They're letting him out!
Mmm...
By the way...
What's going on with that other case?
The junkyard murder.
She did it, eh?
No question about it?
...
I don't want to...
She's been a bad little baby.
Disappeared from the scene like that.
Wonder where she ran off to play.
No...
What did he just say?
She did it?
Did I hear that right?
I think they were talking about the culprit who killed me.
No way.
Trick time.
Can I possess his feet?
Good lord.
What is this?
Oooh!
I just don't believe it.
Why would she do a thing like that?
Afraid I don't have the answers for you, chief.
I don't want to...
Believe it any more than you do.
And yet...
Stream had a hiccup again?
Hmm...
I wonder why there's so many issues tonight.
Oh, no hiccup here?
After seeing this, maybe we don't have any other choice but to believe, baby.
Is that the security camera tape the investigation unit just delivered?
I can't deny.
It's some pretty solid evidence against her.
Watch, the tape is going to be...
This is some actual Phoenix Wright shit.
Where the tape will be like...
Them standing each other talking...
And then it cuts out...
And then she's like holding his body.
Because the actual murder part...
Gets...
Gets deleted somehow.
I just dropped my fork.
I like it, baby.
It's okay, they're just fries.
I can eat them with my fingies.
I was just trying to avoid greasy hands.
Why a murder case now on such an important night?
Put your feet...
Put your shoes on, man!
Come on!
I think you have that wrong, chief.
Chopsticks are for fries?
Okay.
I didn't want to say...
It was one of those gaming chopsticks.
You know those ones that you like...
Put on your fingers so that you can...
So that you can type on your keyboard.
So I just called it a fork.
Because
I was embarrassed to say...
Oh, I dropped my gaming chopsticks.
No, dang it!
And then you guys started calling me out...
For it being a fork.
No, you guys know what I'm talking about, right?
So you put them in between like your...
Index and your middle finger.
And it like sticks there.
It stays there.
And then you can like...
With your knuckles, you like...
You can...
So you can type.
And also have the chopsticks on your fingers.
The little tweezer looking things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like barely chopsticks at all.
But like...
That's what I was using.
I was embarrassed to say it.
Now I think I'm even more embarrassed.
Trying to imagine.
Let me see if I can get a picture real quick.
Oh no!
I hate this image so much.
Okay.
This is what they're like.
This is what they're...
This
is what I was using.
Oh no!
Advanced Gamer.
Yeah, because I was holding my controller.
And eating my fries.
Now you know.
I'd be embarrassed too.
I love my cringe Oshii.
A murder case now.
For the very reason that...
He is such an important guy.
To his toes.
Let's see.
What else can I do?
Alarm.
Speaker.
Oh, let's lower the screen.
Let's watch the tape.
After all.
Oh.
They don't seem to care at all actually.
The junkyard where I died had a security camera.
And it captured the moment of my death perfectly.
Okay.
And what the tape showed me.
Was the cruelest truth imaginable.
Uh oh.
Oh my god.
We're moving.
We're alive.
It was...
I don't know.
Oh my god.
That briefcase has been there the whole time.
Did she actually?
I was wrong.
Yeah.
That's pretty conclusive.
I would say so.
I saw myself shot right before my own eyes.
By Lin.
There goes my only lead.
I feel like I've died all over again.
Unless.
Unless they were blanks.
Right?
They must have been blanks.
And then when I died for real.
She was like.
Oh my god.
What?
One thing sticks with me though.
Lin looked so surprised on that tape.
What in the world did I tell her?
The truth is the truth.
No matter how many times you watch it.
Inspector Cabanela.
It wasn't me who played the tape just now baby.
Oh by the way.
Okay.
We're just gonna ignore that fact.
Okay Inspector Cabanela.
There's something on that tape that troubles me.
What is that Chief?
I'm all ears.
I had a look at all the photos of the crime scene as well.
But...
The place where the victim was shot.
And where the body was found.
Is clearly different.
No.
Didn't we know that reason?
He got pushed down.
Didn't he?
By the bad guy.
Yeah.
He got kicked and fell over.
So we knew that already.
Yeah.
The hitman in black is the one who kicked me downstairs.
But I changed his fate.
So he should have been...
I changed his fate.
So he should have been out of the picture.
That's right.
But there I am.
Down on the lower level.
It's hard to remember what happened before.
I have the answer to your mystery right here.
A few minutes after the murder took place.
Okay.
Nice.
Security cameras that actually work.
This is insane.
Do I just fall over?
Why was there a cat in my briefcase?
What?
Is that a black cat?
You got it, baby.
A furry feline messed up our crime scene.
And then the little cat pulper vanished into the night.
Hmm.
Looks like my destiny of being knocked downstairs is very hard to alter.
Uh oh.
This is point X.
Come in, chief.
Oh my god.
The chief here?
Did he show up?
No, sir.
Not yet, but...
Idiot.
I told you to stay off the radio unless it was so important.
But this is important, sir.
Somebody else showed up.
Our rookie detective, Lynn.
Ruh-roh.
You see my baby over there, do you?
I heard she was on the lam.
What do you want me to do, chief?
What do you say, inspector?
There's no time for dancing.
Detective.
Get my baby away from point X.
Uh oh.
The launch codes.
Maybe the...
I think we know where they're touching down.
Do it now, man.
And then hold on to her.
Yes, sir.
I'll get her right now, sir.
What is the meaning of this?
Why would Lynn show up here?
Why would she show up at point X?
It took the special investigation unit six months to pinpoint that location.
Don't know, chief.
But I'd say it wasn't a coincidence.
Perhaps...
It was a ghost trick.
What?
Uh oh.
Now what?
What happened this time?
Damn it.
Why did his feet do that?
This calls for a telephone call to point X.
Allow me.
Oh, yeah, you're allowed.
Trick time, baby.
No time to waste.
Oh.
Uh.
Maybe just a little bit of time.
Why is he doing that with his feet?
Just a little bit of time to waste.
And then we lower it.
And then we...
Then we go telephone it.
What are you doing?
Get your buns over here.
Oh, shit.
Is that her on the ground?
What did you say?
Now I finally understand.
I finally know what it's like to murder!
Oh.
For our poor hungry customers who have their food deliveries delayed.
Excuse me?
I think he needs to go to a doctor for that.
What is going on with your nose?
But this is the chicken kitchen, is it not?
What?
Aren't I talking to the police?
The police?
Did something happen there you need assistance with?
Something happened here, you ask?
More like there's nothing left here.
I gotta go.
Wait!
Someone is down.
This itchy footed man.
Why?
You're so nasty.
What is that?
What's that called?
Athlete's foot or something?
I'm getting my fork.
Off the ground.
My fork.
Okay.
What's going on?
Something, that's what.
Something is definitely going on.
And that something is far from nothing.
That's for certain.
So poetic.
Thanks for the tea, Chief.
I'll be on my way.
You going to Point X?
Point X, eh?
I'll leave that to the boys.
There's someplace else I gotta be.
Inspector.
Mint, if your feet are ever itchy, I'm here for you, Queen.
Thanks.
Your being there isn't going to change anything.
Why put yourself through it?
I have a responsibility and I'm going to see it through to the end.
Okay, maybe he's not a bad guy.
I can't tell, actually.
Besides, it's not quite over yet.
Right, that's true.
Do what you must then.
Oh, God.
They're so jittery.
Prisoner D99's schedule for tomorrow was blank.
Seems like forever ago that I found that out.
Now my mind is even blanker than that blackboard was.
Lynn, my only lead.
And my partner shot me.
What did it all mean?
I knew where I had to go to get my answers.
The chicken kitchen.
The point X the police have surrounded.
And the place where something big just happened.
What will Lynn be involved in this time when I find her there?
I kind of want to see...
Does he go to the jail?
Yay!
Oh, I didn't even realize there were stairs over there.
We just didn't look.
I didn't even realize there were stairs down there.
Well, I tried to move, but it just wouldn't let me.
I was stuck in the jail.
New song.
Save the data.
Nice.
Alright, let's keep going.
Wait, how long have I...
Okay, almost 4 hours.
Chapter 7!
We're almost...
Wait, it's what?
19 chapters?
18?
19?
I just can't get the images I saw at police headquarters out of my head.
The person who shot me tonight.
It's the last person in the world I want to believe did it.
18.
Okay.
We're almost halfway there.
Now I'm here at the place she and I agreed to meet.
The restaurant the police were staking out as Point X.
But when I got there, I found the place in ruins.
Maybe another 2-3 more streams.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
Unless I...
Unless I, like, endurance the last part.
Or the next part.
What in the world happened here?
Big chicken!
Oh my god, she's dead!
She's dead!
Oh, the heavens!
What do I do?
If I had known something like this would happen?
He's so smiley about it though.
I would have paid the poor child more!
I would have cooked more chicken for her!
I would have sung to her as much as she liked!
Until she had her fill!
Actually, about the singing.
She did tell me she had a filler.
The chef seems to be in quite a panic.
Oh, she's dead!
She's so cute though!
You're too cute to die!
At least it doesn't look like the waitress is dead.
Oh, just kidding.
But this guy is!
That guy sure seems to be dead.
We're just gonna roll down here.
According to that police radio conversation, she should be here.
But I don't see her anywhere.
Seems like bad luck is in it for that redhead.
So I was half expecting to see her in trouble again.
Oh my gosh, that's great.
I have an itch underneath the thing I put...
the hot patch I put on my shoulders.
But I can't get to it because it's...
Ow!
I'm good.
I spotted the corpse of the van driver.
That poor guy...
Oh, wait!
She's there!
Oh my god!
Why?
She was there!
Look at me!
I'm dead!
What took you so long?
Well, that's one way to greet a guy.
What happened here?
How should I know?
I'm the victim!
Is it just my imagination?
Or is she getting more and more brazen...
every time she dies?
Well, that's because I'm a detective.
Have to be tough, you know.
Well, and...
How did it go?
Did you check out tomorrow's work schedule for prisoner D99?
Uh oh.
Yeah, just like I promised.
Actually, I have a few things I want to ask...
I want to ask you about too.
Sure!
We agree to use each other after all, right?
The troublesome...
GF experience?
Oh, no British accent?
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Let's swap info then.
Let's save my murderer for last, right?
Let's start with point...
We'll work our way up.
Point X.
The police were staking this restaurant out tonight.
They called it Point X.
Point X, huh?
That's a good name for this place.
That white suited inspector was in surprise to find out...
you just casually waltzed in here.
Inspector Cabanela?
What in the world made you pick this place anyway?
I guess I'd have to say...
because of you.
Me?
What did I do?
Every time she dies, she gets a new accent.
She dies as much as Maya gets arrested...
in Ace Attorney?
So true.
You remember that note I found?
The note I didn't get a chance to read.
She sent a time written on it.
The chicken kitchen, 10pm.
In other words...
I was supposed to meet...
somebody here tonight.
Yup, apparently so.
I just had to get that information...
you were going to give me.
Or I just had to get that information...
That's why I came here.
It was the only lead I had left.
Ahhhh...
So this here is Point X.
That's mean.
The mark the police were waiting for was mean?
I feel like the music is a little too light-hearted...
for what's going on.
Just like you said, each prisoner had a little blackboard...
in his cell.
But the thing is...
there wasn't anything written on Prisoner D99's blackboard.
It was blank.
What?
I guess maybe it means his schedule for tomorrow...
hasn't been decided yet?
Blank?
Huh?
I didn't lose it over a blank blackboard.
How come you're so upset about an undecided work schedule?
Oh man...
I get the feeling that...
back when I was alive...
I never had much of a schedule to worry about myself.
Do you know what it means...
when a prisoner doesn't have a schedule for the next day?
It means something?
Oh gosh.
Cecil please!
It doesn't mean he doesn't have work to do.
It's more like...
he can't work.
Because he's dead!
He's going to be...
executed!
Aha.
Executed?
Uh oh.
Oh!
Execution.
Do you know what Prisoner D99's crime was?
I think so.
They said something about him...
murdering his wife...
right in front of a family member.
Her.
That's what they say...
but it's not true.
He would never...
Detective Joud would never do anything like that!
The death penalty...
hasn't been enforced in this country for a very long time.
They're trying to get rid of him...
because he knows something.
Not for decades.
Even if the prisoner wants it.
Like in this case.
The prisoner wants it?
There's definitely something else...
going on with this case.
I just know it.
And I have to find out what.
And if his work schedule is blank for tomorrow...
I have to do it right now!
So this Prisoner D99...
Detective Joud...
He must be connected to me in some way too.
Are we not going to mention that he had me drawn on his...
little... yeah.
Look at that.
It's beautiful.
Captures my best side and everything.
After all, he obviously knows me.
At last, my murderer.
On my way here...
I stopped by the Chief of Police's office.
Do you think he has a skip?
Oh...
It was just on your way, was it?
And while I was there, I saw who did it.
I saw my murderer.
You saw him?
Where?
How?
Not him.
Her.
There was a security camera set up there...
at the junkyard where I got shot.
The security tape showed me...
the person who shot me.
It was you.
And it was not AI generated.
Flashback...
Were we possessed by the lamp?
Was she possessed by the lamp maybe?
No way...
You're kidding, right?
What do you have to say for yourself, detective?
It wasn't me!
I didn't shoot!
If I recall, this is what you said about who shot me.
My memory just isn't clear on that part.
So how can you say for sure that it wasn't you?
B-because I told you before!
You were supposed to give me some information!
The lamp?
Yeah...
The lamp...
Information, huh?
Maybe that information was the reason you shot me.
What?
What do you mean?
Ba-ding!
Why she shot me...
What's the chat summary?
You said you had some information on the case I'm looking into.
So I would hardly shoot you before I even heard that information, right?
I agree.
That wouldn't make sense.
If it was before...
Huh?
But what if it was after you already got the information from me?
Bum-bum-ba-bum-bum-bum.
Oh, she looks shocked.
I definitely told you something then.
I killed...
...the lady.
She's like, no, you...
No.
And whatever it was, it really shocked you.
What did I tell you?
I don't remember.
I don't know!
You've got to believe me!
After you saved me, I thought I got all of my memories back.
But maybe I really didn't.
I killed Bufasa.
I am your father.
Luke.
You told me something.
I can't remember that part at all.
Because we were possessed.
You got the information you wanted from me.
And then you shot me.
Isn't that what happened?
No, no, I didn't shoot you!
Please tell me.
What did you tell me that time?
How am I...
You know I have no memories.
I can't even read!
What did I learn from you?
So, what are you going to do now?
I mean, you fulfilled your goal, right?
You found out who shot you.
Are you going to get revenge?
That would be easy enough to do.
All you have to do is not save me.
Oh...
It's kind of a dilemma, huh?
If I don't save her...
Um...
You know, I end the game in this stream.
Is this the ending I was hoping for?
Had I unraveled all of the mysteries of me?
Gosh, I can see why so many people say this is their favorite game ever.
It just ends like that!
That's it!
That's the story!
What am I going to do now?
I'm going to save you, that's what.
You are?
I want to know everything.
Who I was.
Why I was killed.
Yeah, I'd like to know who those guys are too.
The little blue guys.
And the grapes.
I want answers.
And I'm going to find them.
But to do that, I'm going to need your help.
Okay.
I won't say thank you.
Not yet.
And I won't say I'm sorry either.
But I'll help see to it that you get your answers.
Good.
Now I think it's time to go back to the past.
I can't leave you lying flattened under a huge chunk of chicken forever after all.
Alrighty, guys.
Let's solve this chicken dinner.
Let's cook this roast.
I mean...
Let's prep this roast.
The note says the chicken kitchen, 10pm.
I wonder if that pointy haired man was going to meet here.
You know my name.
You know I'm Sissel.
What's this?
Today's special.
Oh my gosh.
She's so cute.
She's so...
Whoa, I thought...
Oh my gosh.
I thought that was like an alien lady for a second.
Bing bong.
I don't think she fits the vibe of this restaurant.
I love it though.
Can...
Yeah, can someone convince Kiara to get a skater outfit like that next?
Can someone please convince her?
We need like a...
Can I eat that thing?
Oh my gosh, Lin, please.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
No!
Phew!
Lin's got moves.
Yeah, she do.
You're just going bigger and better with each new death, aren't you?
Leave me alone.
Can I help it if I got tired of dying the usual ways?
You could have just moved, Lin.
You could have just moved.
But I'll say this.
It was a death any detective could be proud of.
Huh?
What makes you say that?
Because you saved her.
You saved a girl the way you save someone else before dying yourself.
Oh, that waitress?
The one with the chicken on her head?
The next time you put a chicken on your head, you should try one about the size of the waitress's.
I'll make a note of that for next time.
But anyway...
If you hadn't tried to save that waitress, you'd still be alive.
No, no.
We're not choosing lives here.
I couldn't help it.
You know, the detective thing and all.
I wasn't able to save that poor van driver, though.
I don't think there's no helping that guy.
At the speed, he must have died instantly.
Well, we can't let a heroic detective like you stay dead.
The root of this whole disaster is clear.
Chicken.
The question is...
How do I stop it?
Okay, let's get started!
Hmm...
Uh...
Trick time...
Okay...
Menu board...
Sign...
Let's ring the bell!
Uh...
Trick.
Hello, ma'am!
Oh my god, she's so cute!
She's so cute!
You rang?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't ring the bell.
Okay, I get it.
This was a little dig, wasn't it?
Kind of like, hey, where's my food, right?
No, not at all!
Besides, I didn't ring it.
Oh, okay.
That's all right then.
But the chef is the one who makes the chicken.
No sense in harassing me about it, right?
Just keep that in mind, okay?
Bye!
Odd girl.
I agree.
Me too.
What's wrong with her?
She didn't do anything.
What's this?
It's no use.
I can't read what it says.
Oh, let's see.
Now I remember what the sign says.
Please ring the bell three times.
Okay.
The waitress doesn't bring any water if you only ring the bell once.
She said those are the rules apparently.
I said apparently?
What do you mean apparently?
Don't you work here?
Quite a stickler for the details, this detective.
Okay.
So let's...
You wrote this note, right?
I think so, but I don't remember.
10 o'clock.
That means it's already time for your meeting with whoever it is.
Now that I think about it.
Whoever you were supposed to meet might already be here.
You think the detective...
You're the detective.
Whoa.
I can't read anymore.
Shouldn't you have checked out when you got here?
Sorry, the chicken at this restaurant is really good.
So, you know.
No, I don't know.
Take a look around the rest of the restaurant.
Okay.
We're zooming around.
Wow.
That's fancy.
But there's these guys.
Time is passing.
And then her.
Aren't you going to deliver my food?
The chicken is just sitting there.
What are you doing with that?
Okay, we hit it.
Three times.
Give me my water.
Thank you, ma'am.
Water.
You want more water?
I stay hydrated.
What's your issue?
Sorry, I didn't ring the bell.
And what's with the more water bit?
Oh, well, come on.
This is your third glass.
Okay, I get it.
This was a little dig, wasn't it?
Oh, where's my food?
I'll see you bringing me my chicken soon.
Duly noted.
In the meantime, enjoy a nice glass of water.
Thank you.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Okay.
What do they say?
What's taking my chicken so long?
Fortunately for you, according to what we saw before, the van arrives before your chicken's done.
In any case, just hanging around here isn't going to fix anything.
I'll have to look for a way to get beyond this area.
Oh, when she comes over, I have to...
One, two, three...
Sorry, I'm bullying her a little bit.
I'm harassing the...
There we go.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
Nice.
Trick time.
Uh...
To the cart!
And...
There it is.
I was like, are we going to go up?
Time is passing.
Do you think this girl likes her job?
I think if I could rollerblade everywhere, I would be very excited about that.
Oh wait, what did he say?
Here you go.
That's a big trunk.
This is one big trunk.
Seems pretty heavy too.
It's very suspicious.
And red.
My body is in there!
Let's see what's in it.
Sorry, but that's not possible.
It's locked.
Darn.
I wanted to see what was inside.
Okay, now we can eavesdrop on these guys.
So what do you think, my dear beauty?
Do you really think we can trust this deal?
Who knows?
It's not our job to think about that.
But those incidents did happen in this country, just as he predicted.
Yes, and they were pretty amusing too, weren't they?
That fellow who sang out national secrets during live TV broadcasts.
And the man who laid siege to the Metro Police Department, taking the top dog hostage.
Well, what if he double-crosses us?
It wouldn't be pretty.
How do these two...
How do they know about the cases at the special prison?
Yeah.
That guy's voice is so...
I know, right?
Great voice acting.
Thank you.
Well, wouldn't everyone know about the secrets?
Because it happened at a concert?
Like...
One of those cases...
And recently, too.
The perpetrators in those cases are being held at a special facility.
That's what the special prison is.
But it's not known about it by the general public.
So Prisoner D-99, Detective Jowd is one of these special cases, too, huh?
Oh, they...
It's a cover-up.
They erase the concert-goers' memories?
They have the power to do that?
They silence the crowd?
These two are talking about the very same cases I heard about just tonight.
How convenient.
Also, this guy's, like...
Margarita glass head is crazy.
That couldn't be just a coincidence, could it?
Is that a whip she's holding?
Or is that a...
That's not a cane.
What is her beauty?
Why don't we move to a different spot?
Waiter?
All the way over there.
That table in the back looks good.
Oh, now you're talking beauty, my dear.
Just what I've been waiting for.
A quiet, secluded spot.
Just the two of us.
I wouldn't object to that.
Well...
All of the sudden, I get this feeling somebody is...
eavesdropping.
My sixth sense is very strong, you know.
She...
Oh my god, she's noticing me?
Okay, beauty.
That's alright, my dear.
You don't have to make excuses.
Off we go across the bridge of poultry.
To the land of love.
Wait!
Take the chicken!
No, no, no!
No!
Oh, we get to watch them...
Oh god!
God damn!
Stop with the super chat!
What does that mean?
What just happened?
Did she sense we were here?
What?
With her sixth sense?
But you know, I have some pretty amazing powers myself.
Yeah?
Like what?
Like... like if there's chicken nearby.
I can tell right away.
That's called a sense of smell.
But anyway, at least the situation has changed a little bit now.
Fate...
Changed.
I don't believe in a sixth sense.
It's not scientific!
Says the ghost.
Come to think of it, we've been left behind, haven't we?
Yeah, we're kind of stuck here.
Looks that way.
Not having legs is even more inconvenient than I thought it would be.
What are we going to do now?
They're all the way over there!
I'm telling you, we'd better shake a leg.
We're going to miss what they're saying.
It'd be pretty hard to shake a leg.
Not having legs and all.
Oh my god, he's blowing kisses at her.
They're still talking about something.
I want to hear!
Me too.
Alright, let's figure what...
we're going to do in here.
Maybe they want a drink.
Right?
Can we...
We tried examining this and...
Okay, yeah, it's still the same thing.
Uh...
What is...
What if we dispense a bottle?
Oh!
Okay...
Um...
Uh...
She only comes for one bell here.
Wait!
We make them a drink and she delivers it.
You're right.
Oh, I get it.
You saw that couple over there and you started to get lonely, right?
And so you decided to call me.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Forgive me.
But I didn't ring for anybody.
What?
Could you not stand in my light, please?
I can't see my glass properly.
I've been working here for two days.
And I've been waiting this whole time for you to notice me.
Now, would you stop trying to shake me up and just stick to shaking cocktails?
Okay.
Aww, she's heartbroken with her unrequited love.
She has a surprisingly short career with this place.
Okay.
She's back already.
Oh, so fast.
Okay, trick time.
We're gonna make them a drink.
Oh, it just overflows!
Oh, I thought I could...
Okay.
I didn't realize it was going to be a cutscene.
I thought I would be able to ghost trick it to stop it.
You just broke that glass.
Just like you did my heart.
A broken glass can never be put back to stock.
Just leave it there.
You can't just leave it!
Somebody might get hurt!
Doesn't this trunk belong to that couple over there?
The only things we're allowed customers to lose here are their cares.
Miss, please go and let them know about the trunk.
If you would be so kind.
How gallant of you.
I just might fall for you, you know.
Yippee!
Got it.
Okay.
Oh, odd girl.
I agree.
I...
agree.
Wait, we have to wait for him to put the glass down, maybe.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there it is.
There.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
Almost.
There we go!
Oh my gosh, sorry.
For going back and forth so many times.
Well, goodbye.
I've been working here for two days and I've had my eye on you the whole time.
I think this might be my last night working here though.
What?
It's been fun.
Wait, you just got here!
I guess she's leaving this place with her surprisingly short career intact.
Oh, here he comes.
Of all things to forget, it wouldn't have been pretty if I forgot this.
You know who I'm trying to channel?
Is um...
Thunderburger from...
from Over the Garden Wall.
I think that's who I'm trying to channel.
Alright.
Here we are, finally.
Not Shaggy?
Like Scooby-Doo Shaggy?
No, he's like...
Zoinks.
Like Scoob.
He's got like a totally different voice.
I thought it was Shaggy.
Not at all!
I feel kind of bad about eavesdropping though.
I don't.
Not me.
Yeah.
I'm on Lin's side.
I mean, we just delivered their lost truck to them after all.
They owe us at least that much.
What kind of detective says something like that?
Faith changed.
Uh...
So can we listen in on them?
Now?
Oh!
We can be flowers.
Oh, we can...
Let's swing a little bit.
Oh my god!
I can't believe I forgot the trunk of all things.
Now I'm hearing Shaggy.
With such a small body, you probably only have a small brain to match.
Ouch!
That hurts, beauty!
Now I can't do... Now I'm doing Scooby!
I mean Shaggy.
But like, that's okay.
That's what I love about you.
That's what he loves about her?
Oh my gosh, Lin.
Don't kink-shame.
I don't get it either.
Now where were we?
Oh, right.
To invite to the wedding.
If we got married, that is, of course.
Whip him.
She's like, I'm glad there's nobody around to listen to this.
We can talk about that when we're alone.
But aren't we alone now, beauty?
Do you think she senses our presence again?
I spy a ladybug.
Oh, ladybug.
I just hate little bugs.
Me too.
What?
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Death is imminent, I suppose.
Death is...
After all that trouble, it happened anyway!
It looks that way, yes.
It's not over yet, though.
It's not?
What are you talking about?
You're not dead yet.
No, I'm just...
I'm going to be in just a few seconds.
But before that happens, maybe there's something we can do from here.
Trick time.
Okay.
Swing.
Oh, so close.
So close.
There we go.
Chicken bone.
Oh, my God.
What?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm trying to get to the...
Ah!
There we go.
Double body inspection!
Hello?
It looks like he's unconscious.
Excuse me.
Could you wake up for a second, please?
Pushy as ever, this detective.
One thing I've learned...
is that the most newly dead stay unconscious for a little while at first.
Huh?
I was like that, and you were like that, too.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Anyway, if we restart the flow of time now, you'll die.
Yeah, I know.
Why don't we try going back even further in time?
Even further?
But how?
Simple.
We go back four minutes before the death of this poor driver here.
Whoa!
You can do that?
Yeah!
I never tried it before, so I don't know how it'll go.
But if we can erase the driver's death, that should erase your death, too.
Oh, wow!
I can't think of any other way.
Let's try it.
Rewind!
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh, my God!
Is this guy!
What the?
Yes!
I remember!
Oh, my gosh!
The park!
That's Lin, our rookie detective!
Is he the guy that phones the police station?
What's she doing at point X?
Could it be just a coincidence?
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Yeah!
Parkman and Hippie Man!
Um...
What was I gonna say, though?
I don't remember.
And we just got an APB on her a little while ago.
Something about an extremely important case's extremely important witness currently extremely on the run.
Now what?
Should I report this to Inspector Captain?
Yes, yes, yes!
He talks to him!
So he's the one that signals him.
Ah-ha!
Ha-ha-ha!
Ah!
Time to catch some sleep, Minto.
Enjoy the rest of the stream.
Thank you!
Goodnight!
They told us to stay off the radio unless it was an emergency.
But I think I'd better call this in.
Poor Lin.
I wonder what she did this time.
What do you mean, me?
Inspector Cavanella is pretty protective when it comes to Lin.
He'd want to know.
I'm gonna finish up this case and then we'll end, though.
So once we save this guy...
What's the matter?
Alright.
Fine.
Who called?
And then we call...
people.
This is point X.
Idiot!
Oh, no!
It's important!
Yes, sir.
I'll go get her.
Okay.
I'm glad we got the Cliff Notes version of it.
Wee-woo!
The static is awful.
Eyes on the road, buddy.
Can't believe I forgot the trunk of all things.
Such a small body.
You probably only have a small...
He was listening in!
That's what I love about you.
It was bugged.
I spy a ladybug.
Thank you for the...
I don't know.
Jason Funderburker.
That guy's the total package.
A ladybug.
I just hate little bugs.
It was bugged.
I can't hear very well.
Aha!
So...
When she lit it on fire!
Mm-hmm.
Dang.
I can't believe he crashed.
This is why you wear your seat belts, first of all.
I can't believe he crashed so crazily that even the steering wheel broke off.
Rip his eardrums.
This is you listening to...
That's you when you listen to VTuber streams sometimes, isn't it?
You hear the scream and you're just like, I'm being sent to heaven!
The van driver was a detective.
Looks like it.
I noticed something, though.
That conversation he was listening to just before the crash.
I remember hearing it before.
You're right.
We heard it just a few minutes ago, didn't we?
When you were doing one of your karaoke streams...
What do you mean by that?
I don't scream during my karaoke streams.
Are you saying that your ears are not blessed during my karaoke?
Are you saying that I'm a shit singer?
Fine.
Everybody, you can thank Ninebreaker for me never doing another karaoke stream ever again.
Oh.
Not And I'll never ever again... get one guide.
Just after that conversation, the detective suddenly passed out.
What happened, I wonder?
Oh, I know what happened.
We already know the answer.
We saw what happened at the restaurant.
Yeah, she lit the little bug on fire.
Ba-bam, she burned up the ladybug.
Sometimes, when a high-tech bug like that is destroyed, it emits a loud signal.
I regret nothing.
I respect it.
He's like, if I go down, I'm going down with dignity.
You know what?
Stick to your ideals.
If that's what you believe, then you know what?
Don't just change your ideas because everybody else doesn't agree with you.
That's your opinion.
He accomplished his mission.
I respect it.
Stand proud.
He's still getting lynched though.
No, no, no, I'm not wrong.
The world is.
He basically said that.
So funny.
Find something to believe in, write in, even if it's, even if it's Min's terrible singing.
Loud enough to knock a person out if they were listening to it through headphones.
So that's why the detective passed out, huh?
Bingo.
Now let's stop it from happening.
Trick time.
Oh.
Oh, I was like, why was a soul there?
This is the place that the white suited inspector phone tonight.
This
is a parking lot of the park on the east side of town.
It's been years.
You know this park?
Yeah, I used to play here a lot when I was little.
But then one day, I swore I'd never set foot in this park ever again.
Because her father killed her mum.
Whoa, those are some really deep, dark feelings there.
I wonder what happened.
Hold it!
Don't give me that.
A ghost doesn't have a foot to set bit.
It's just a figure of speech.
What kind of nitpicker do you think I am?
Anyway, whatever.
Let's get started.
Okay, let's do that.
I won't press her about that other thing right now.
Let's see.
We can go to his flashlight.
We can go to his seat lever.
Oh yeah, let's put that down.
What?
Oh.
I guess we can...
Flashlight.
Wee woo, wee woo.
Doesn't look like the detective is going to come.
Thank god.
Might as well turn it off.
It's pretty loud.
Hold it.
What else can we get to?
Time is passing.
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
And he's going to throw his binoculars.
And we can probably...
Yep.
Go to the binoculars.
They told us to stay off the radio unless it was an emergency.
But I think we can do it.
I think I better call this in.
Poor Lin.
I wonder what she did this time.
What does he mean this time?
Mind your own business.
I like to do things my...
My way, okay?
Did she...
Accidentally kill her dad?
Or her mom?
And that's why the...
The...
The guy...
In prison...
...is wanting to take the fall.
You know?
Like, what if she was a kid and she was just messing around?
Kind of like...
You know?
She was just messing around with her dad...
Her dad's a detective.
She's like, I wanna be like daddy too!
And...
She was playing with the gun...
And accidentally went off...
And killed her mom.
And so that's why the dad was just like, oh my gosh...
I have to do the death penalty.
Because...
I can't let my daughter take the fall.
She was just a kid.
That's my current theory.
You got a cart before the horse.
That's...
Inspector Cabanela is pretty protective...
When it comes to Lin.
He'd want to know.
And because...
Because they're close...
He's just like...
He probably does not want her to become a detective.
The Inspector Cabanela guy.
Right?
Because it's just like...
The same thing could happen to you.
But there's also all the other guys too.
I don't know.
I'm still cooking.
Oh!
So why are we involved?
Good question.
I'm cooking is all.
This is why I don't cook.
Who is the detective talking to?
Don't keep yelling at me about these little things.
But they might be talking about something ridiculously important.
That's true.
But still...
It might be the person who really shot you.
Now you're just throwing things out there.
But in any case...
It looks like it's too late to get to the phone now.
I think we missed her.
But I didn't have a chance.
It didn't let me when he walked by.
I'm worried about that detective mem...
Mem... memory?
Who's the hell...
Who's detective memory?
They call her the Lin of the Special Investigation Unit.
Is that a bad thing?
Well, well...
Did you hear that, detective?
At least it's better than me being called the memory of the detective division.
At any rate...
I'd better report to Inspector Cabanela before I worry about that listening device.
Yeah, see?
When he's walking around...
I missed my chance.
Should I restart, but...
Point X.
Safe here?
Did he show up?
No sir, not yet.
Blah blah blah!
I told you to stay off the radio!
Okay, this is important!
It's Lynn!
My baby!
What do you want me to do?
Get my baby away from point X!
Do it now, man!
Okay.
Now here.
He's on the move!
There isn't much time left.
We have to stop him.
Fast!
Otherwise he's going to crash into the chicken kitchen!
This is like that game, isn't it?
GTA?
Oh, game of chicken!
Sorry, but what's a game of chicken?
Sorry.
I'd better choose my audience more carefully the next time I tell a joke.
Never mind that.
We have to do something!
Okay, let's put a seat down.
And if we do...
Yeah, we still can't reach.
If we put the seat down...
He will...
Maybe the headphones will fly off.
Recline!
Wow!
What do you think you're doing?
I just thought I'd...
I'd better do something.
Never mind.
I can't!
It's too heavy!
How weak is this car?
The steering wheel come off every time.
All I can hope is...
This guy has strong ab muscles.
I don't think he dies.
Somehow sped his death up.
Time's up.
Oops, that was my bad.
I get that you felt like you had to do something, but that...
Well, there really isn't much I can do once the van is moving.
We should rethink this.
Was there any other path before that?
Okay.
From the beginning.
From the top, everybody.
From the top.
I... Okay.
Can you think of...
My logic wasn't so bad, though.
Right?
My logic was pretty sound, I'd say.
Oh, that opened.
That's so cute.
What the...
It opens a little...
It opens a little thing.
So cute.
Was it though?
Yeah!
I think...
I think I was...
How do I get over there?
Oh, maybe I make a lot of noise.
And when he's trying to listen...
Yeah, there we go.
He's like, turn that blasted thing off.
Oh!
Did the binoculars get launched by the seat?
Pew!
Oh!
Uh...
Did I do the wrong order?
Wait, what do you mean?
Just reset?
Okay, okay, I'll reset.
Uh, yeah, because we want to hear the phone call.
Okay, so he's gonna...
Okay, let's see.
What the...
What is this?
I'm confused.
What's the order that I'm supposed to do?
Binocular before siren.
Okay.
Pew!
Oh, and then he picks them up.
And then he carries them to the...
to the thing.
Okay, I think I get it.
Wee woo!
Oh.
Yeah.
What are these doing here?
Wait, let me, let me, let me, let me...
Please!
There we go.
Okay.
Now we follow him.
Okay, okay.
Good, good, good, good.
Okay.
What's the matter?
Here we go.
Honk!
Detective Ringe?
This is memory.
She's memory!
Thanks for the super chat.
What's the matter?
It's not time for your regular report.
Did she just miss me?
Listen to this.
There's a suspicious couple in the bar upstairs.
I'm going to put a ladybug on them.
A ladybug?
You mean a listening device?
Don't do anything to blow our cover.
Inspector Cabanela will be furious.
But they are doing all kinds of suspicious whispering.
We have to find out what they're saying.
You can pick up on the signal from your van.
Check out their conversation for me, would you?
Alright, fine.
Once you get going on something, I know there's no stopping you.
Okay, so we have to figure out a way for her to change the position of the bug.
Okay.
Thanks.
Later then.
She's the murderer.
Hold on.
Did you see a customer come in just now?
A young woman with red hair and red boots?
Oh yeah, that restless suspicious chick?
Sure.
Suspicious?
I mean, come on.
As soon as she sat down, she ordered three glasses of water in a row.
And she spilled the second glass on the table.
Okay, fine.
Keep your eye on her too, if you would.
You got it.
Oh wow, that waitress was an undercover agent.
And she apparently thought you were pretty suspicious too.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I was really thirsty.
Um, no, I don't know.
Anyway, did you hear about what I heard?
About the listening device?
We have to do something about that bug.
So we have to stay here and follow up on the waitress.
Looks like it's time to make a decision.
Go there!
Can't even be a dojiko without being called suspicious these days.
Alright, SMH.
Okay, trace complete.
We're in the kitchen.
We're cooking for real.
Whoa.
He just cooked the whole thing on a frying pan.
Look where we are.
The heart of the chicken kitchen.
I keep wanting to say the kitchen chicken.
I keep wanting to mix them up.
Whereas most people say the kitchen.
I hope the key to preventing that incident is in the kitchen.
It's here somewhere.
Oh, I bet it will be.
You know what they say.
Where there's smokin' chicken, there's fire.
Now that you mention it, it is pretty smoky in here.
Fate changed.
Let's see what we got in here.
We got a little t-shirt.
Scrunch and stretch.
A switch that we can turn on.
That's the phone.
What does this do?
Oh.
Oh my god.
So cute.
A pie.
And the kettle.
Rock that kettle.
Never mind.
Do you think that's...
Oh, she's doing it right now.
She's probably planting the ladybug.
Now that I think about it.
It's this waitress's meddling that starts the whole chain of events.
Exactly.
The detective wouldn't have gotten his ears blown out and wouldn't have crashed.
In other words, we're witnessing it with our own eyes.
The cause of a huge disaster slowly being planted in a chicken.
Hey, I just had a good idea.
The outfit reminds me of something.
It reminds me of the waitress outfit that Maya wears as an ace attorney.
About what to do about the ladybug?
We could get her crushed under the chicken instead of me.
No!
I can't tell if you're kidding.
At any rate, now we've seen the root cause of the incident.
And all we have to do now is think of a way to take care of it.
Lin is literally suggesting murder right now.
What is in his hat?
I think that's wine.
I think that's a bottle.
Oh my god, you guys.
If you ever start seeing Matara wearing a suspiciously large hat...
It's Remy?
No!
It's not Remy.
I can't tell.
What's this switch?
It's smoky in here.
What's wrong?
I can't seem to raise this switch.
It won't budge.
It's not surprising considering this whole place is sticky with grease.
I bet it must be stuck.
It does feel pretty sticky.
It's orange?
It's alive?
But if the switch... Wait, really?
Wait.
But if the switch were already raised, I bet I could manage to lower it.
Oh, you're right.
What is in there?
What's in the hat?
Maybe it's his head?
Maybe he's got... Remember the other guy that...
Maybe they're related.
Him and the other guy that likes the curry and chicken.
Him and the curry and chicken guy are related.
Oh, she's raising it.
Oh, not bad.
There we go.
And lift.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
It was really smoky in there.
And turn it off.
She's still trying to bug that thing.
Oh, see!
I told you it was a bottle of... You guys all said it was a rat!
You all said it was a rat!
Uh...
Can I use... I don't think I can attach...
Oh, I think I need to be on his hat so I can get to the lower stuff.
Maybe.
There we go.
Operating this...
Oh!
Hey,
what's up with this lazy Susan?
It's acting up today.
Maybe it's out of sorts because I was spinning around...
Oh, I know what we need to do!
I know what we need to do!
We need to make it smoky.
While she's working on setting up the... lifting the thing, we gotta switch it so she doesn't realize that we switched them.
I get it now.
I get it.
I get it, I get it, I get it!
Okay, it's a matter of timing once again.
Oh, maybe it's out of sorts.
How about thinking...
Maybe it might be broken?
But it really isn't broken.
It's just us ghosts.
Oh, we're stuck here though.
Uh oh.
We're stuck here.
Until we can get through.
Oh!
Uh oh, I think I just did the timing bad.
Alright.
So from here...
We'll wait.
We'll wait in the hat.
Hopefully the timing works.
Hopefully it gets nice and stuffy.
It's smoky in here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yes!
Alright, now we wait.
There we go!
Okay, that should be it.
That should be it.
Sugoi genius ghost made.
I should be a detective, shouldn't I?
There, all set!
Nice.
There, how about that?
The ladybug is still sitting on the table.
We did it!
Chicken Thou art so beautiful Chicken Chicken Chicken You just Oh, I took a bite My heart swelled with pride And I got goosebumps What the heck is this?
Chicken
Chicken, chicken, chicken.
Looks like you've escaped the fate of being hammered by your horrible head.
Yes, but I still haven't escaped the worst darkness of this terrible night.
I shot you, didn't I?
Don't sing too much, you might shock the poor driver's ears.
Oh my god, I'm now the cause of the incident.
There must have been some sort of complicated set of circumstances that made you do it.
It's never okay to shoot a person, no matter what the circumstances.
Hey, shouldn't be that... shouldn't that be my line?
But anyway...
You were investigating a case, and I was supposed to give you information on that case.
Maybe it's time you told me about it.
Tell me about the case you're looking into.
Yes, I guess I should.
Well, let's go back to the new present first.
Okay, sure.
Okay.
Back to the present.
I thought there would be music so I could drink my water.
Back in the new present, the delicious aroma of chicken fills the air.
But I'm still thinking about Lin.
I wonder if she's still waiting for her chicken to be served.
I decided to go see her.
See her and ask her the questions that were still consuming me.
Not concerning you.
Okay.
Consuming.
I'm still stuck here until this guy decides to...
Until this guy... I'm still... I'm still... Oh, there we go.
Why is there even a button down here?
Um, the chicken kitchen?
Okay.
Very good.
If this was a cheese restaurant, I would have said, very gouda.
The disastrous accident has been completely erased.
Once again, I've saved the red-headed detective from death.
Saved Lin, the criminal who stole my life.
And you saved another man's life too.
Let's not forget about that as well.
But also, what were those guys doing upstairs?
Boo!
I know you guys would like it.
Thank you.
You guys are too kind.
Oh my gosh.
One question in particular hangs heavy on my mind.
Why did she shoot me?
Till I know the answer, I'll never be satisfied.
Oh!
Wait, maybe she's actually related to the other guy.
Meanwhile, Lin's appetite is apparently foremost in her mind.
A golden brown chicken sits on the table in front of her.
Until she eats the whole thing, she'll probably never be satisfied.
Wait, how do we get over there?
Telephone book, menu board...
She's not holding on to anything.
Oh, I didn't know you were here, Detective Range.
Come to see me, didn't you?
Aw, that's so sweet.
Oh hi, memory.
Uh, don't mind us.
Just pretend we're not here.
Why don't you try some chicken while you're here?
No thanks.
Oh, the water.
That's right.
I gotta do the water thingy.
Just watching Lin eat is quite enough for me.
So, how'd it turn out?
With my ladybug.
Oh, that listening device?
Well, let's see.
I thought the gentleman had a very nice singing voice.
Sorry, but we're in the middle of an important talk.
Could you leave us to it?
But you guys are the ones who called me over.
Yeah, we need her to be holding the pitcher.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Me too.
She needs to be...
Oh wait, that's right.
One, two, three.
There it is.
Did you decide you want some chicken?
Or me?
Miss Memory.
She flirts with anything that breeds.
We didn't call you.
Sorry, but could you give us some privacy?
No, stay right there.
Huh?
I'm at the crucial moment with this chicken here.
I'll need you to pour me some water if it starts going down wrong.
Lynn, you don't have to risk your life over chicken, you know.
Oh my god, we're gonna have to save her from the chicken.
He's right.
Look at her attacking that thing.
I definitely want her...
Calm down there, Momo.
Calm down there, okay?
Anyway, I better move now while I have the chance.
Tricked her.
Oh, that's funny.
Even though I just saved that detective, he doesn't have a core.
Not like the one Lynn had.
Or that valiant little doggy missile.
Maybe because he was unconscious, we couldn't talk to him.
I thought the ones I save are supposed to develop a core when they're alive again.
I guess I still have things to learn about these powers of the dead.
That man has no soul.
I'm heading back now.
Lots of things to do, you know.
Yeah, like washing dishes and planting bugs.
Someday I'll plant a big one on you, detective.
She's so forward.
Goodness, girl.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Me too.
Bing, bing.
Listen, Lynn.
You've explained your side and I understand.
But there's an APB out on you.
Can't you at least hurry up and get out of here?
You know, slip away quietly?
Me three.
No can do.
I'm meeting somebody here.
Meeting somebody?
Oh yeah, that's right.
The little lady, Camilla.
But why do you have to meet somebody here?
The Special Investigation Unit is watching this restaurant.
Now, how can that be a coincidence?
I don't know, but it is a coincidence.
Yeah, where is Camilla?
Hey, is it true what they say?
That you're still looking into Detective Jowd's case on your own?
Inspector Cabanella is worried about you, you know.
I understand how you feel, but just don't do anything crazy, okay?
Odd girl.
What does that supposed to mean?
Um... huh?
Odd girl.
Pointing at me.
Hmm?
Time to invade her brain.
So how's that chicken you've been waiting so long for?
It's great!
Chicken puff cereal?
No wait, that's Reese's Puffs.
Chicken for breakfast?
No, chicken puff cereal!
They're great!
But you know...
With Detective Ringe...
That's his name by the way, sitting right across from me.
I mean...
He was just dead a few moments ago, right?
That's kind of taking the edge off my appetite.
Oh brother.
This guy stinks!
But he's a great guy.
He understands my situation, he said.
You're thinking of Frosties.
I'm mixing them both up, okay?
I'm mixing everything up, okay?
I knew it.
I already know.
You don't have to tell me.
He's going to give me a pass, just for tonight.
Speaking of Detective Ringe, I noticed something strange.
He doesn't have a core now.
He doesn't?
I thought a core was supposed to show up once I saved somebody.
Hmm, I wonder if...
When he possessed his corpse, he was unconscious, right?
Unconscious, yeah.
He was, wasn't he?
Just like you, you were unconscious the first time I saved you too.
After I saved you, you didn't have a core either.
So for people who are...
See?
I already called it.
For people who are unconscious, when you save them, no core shows up.
I think that's probably what it is.
We had to save her a second time before she regained her memory.
Or regained any...
Sentience?
You might be right.
Okay, I'll leave Ringe to you then.
But I've still got lots of questions for you.
Yeah, I thought you would.
She's just sitting here eating and like...
In her thoughts.
Talking with this ghost.
And the other detective is like...
Lin.
Lin, I know you really love the chicken.
But you just gotta answer me.
Lin.
Lin, just say anything.
Let's get started then.
Oh, okay.
Right now?
Okay.
Let's start with...
Bottom up again.
Bottoms up?
Sure has taken Camilla long enough.
She should have been here by now.
I'm getting really worried.
Me too.
You two are like sisters, aren't you?
That's what Camilla said.
Yep.
That just about sums it up.
It doesn't look like being...
It doesn't look like being worried affected your appetite much though.
Hey, the bigger the crisis, the more a girl's gotta eat.
So true.
I have to make sure Camilla stays safe, no matter what.
Camilla and that music box.
The music box.
Oh my gosh.
We got that last time.
It's been so long since we've heard about it.
Oh yeah.
That wooden box.
That one.
Yeah.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Yippee.
That box was a present from Detective Chowd.
Oh.
From Detective Chowd.
Yes.
It was five years ago.
That box arrived three days after that murder incident.
Sorry.
I was just cooking in my brain.
He must have sent it just before he was arrested.
I was like, what if once the detective went to jail...
he, like, gave her away to another family...
and that's why her and Camilla are like sisters?
And, like, what if...
What if, um, Cecil was the father figure?
But she also didn't know who he was, so...
I guess that doesn't make sense.
Hmm.
He must have sent it just before he was arrested.
Someday when the case is over and everything is settled...
I want you to give this to a certain person.
He said.
Ooh.
So, what's inside?
Oh, no.
Was I the person?
Was Cecil the person?
I don't know.
I can't open it.
Hmm.
That's a shame.
Yeah.
She would have recognized him then.
Hmm.
She wouldn't have been that young?
It was only five years ago?
Oh.
I thought it happened...
I thought it happened a long time ago.
Oh, well.
Detective Ringe works for the Special Investigation Unit.
He said, He said an important deal is set to go down here tonight at this restaurant.
A deal?
Okay, then what if Camilla's the one that shot the guy?
That's Camilla's dad instead.
A deal that could affect the future of our nation.
A nation isn't something that's easily influenced, though.
But that's what he said.
Anyway, it's that couple at the table upstairs.
Oh, yeah.
I heard they're foreigners.
They're waiting for the other party in this deal to show up now.
Those two, huh?
They certainly are an odd pair.
Is this other party they're waiting for?
Watashi?
This is a blue people country.
They're all just smurfs, you guys.
They're just big smurfs.
Don't you know that because there's so much pollution that has happened, the smurfs have mutated?
They've mutated into full-sized people.
Okay?
Moshikashite watashi.
Too much raspberry slurpees country.
Are they still blue?
Yes.
That's why they're blue.
They're just freakishly large smurfs now.
But average human size.
But freakishly...
Really giant, large smurfs.
Every smurf with the giantest fetish is like, Woohoo!
Yeah!
But every other smurf is like, Oh no!
Oh my god.
This is ruining our lives.
We can't even go back home.
We just squish our families.
No!
That's what's happening.
It's kind of hard to imagine, isn't it?
The smurfs.
The smurf population.
Sorry, I'm mixing up all my conversations.
Nobody really knows any of the details of the deal.
Except for one person.
Our favorite guy!
Mr. Breezy Dancer in a white suit.
They say he's been watching the movements.
He's been watching his movements.
Of those two for a long time.
I've never seen him work so frantically on an investigation before.
Inspector Cabanela, eh?
Apparently, you're a real favorite of his.
A favorite?
Yes, well, there's a reason for that.
And what's that?
Uh, the reason?
Inspector Cabanela and Detective Jowd were good friends.
Yeah, I think I remember the prison guard saying something about that.
Oh, my gosh!
Gumshoe!
They joined the detective division the very same day.
They're two very different types, but they were always in friendly competition to be the best.
Detective Jowd was always very particular about and thorough investigation of the crime scene.
Heya!
Oh!
Ha!
Well,
maybe he's also trying to move... I keep switching sides.
I'm like, he did it!
No!
He's a good guy!
He's trying to... he's framing him!
No!
He's trying to find a way to get him out of jail!
Little A, but before I go to bed, I just want to say big congrats on 200k!
Damn it, you're pretty good.
Thanks, ghost of me!
Ghost of me?
Ghost of ghost.
Good night!
Good night, good night.
Now I'm just like, is he moving up the ladder because he wants to be the top dog to not give that guy the death penalty?
So that's how he became head of the special investigation unit.
I take it.
Anyway, Inspector Cabanela took me under his wing.
Because you were the little girl his good friend had saved, huh?
He really looked out for me, helping me study for my detective's exam.
Fudging my exam score...
What
do you mean by that, Lin?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Lin, Lin, Lin, Lin, you didn't... you, you put... you passed.
We don't have someone out here...
A detective out here who... who... who is... she's perfectly capable, everybody.
Lin Neppo, baby.
That goes a little beyond the scope of looking out for you.
Inspector Cabanela, eh?
I wonder what role he plays in everything that's happening tonight.
Okay, okay.
I can't... I wasn't expecting nepotism.
What is going on?
Alright, death row inmate Joward... Jowd.
What is your connection to prisoner D-99, Detective Jowd?
He seems like more than just a co-worker.
Yes, I suppose you have the right to know.
Detective Jowd is my hero.
Hero, huh?
You don't hear that word much anymore.
Hahaha.
She's cute, so I'll allow it.
It's like finding out your doctor used chat GPT.
Oh god, you're right.
It's like, oh, I just googled it on WebMD, obviously.
It's an old-fashioned hero kind of... heroic kind of story.
It happened ten years ago.
Now, just calm down and drop that weapon.
Stay back.
If you come any closer, I'll shoot her.
Okay.
On that day, ten years ago, I was playing in my favorite park.
And then suddenly, somebody grabbed my arm from behind.
I was so scared, I thought I was going to die.
And then...
He appeared.
Detective Jowd!
Ugh.
And then, that really loud sound.
I think it was the sound of a gun.
I passed out.
When I came to...
Oh my gosh, his baby.
You're all right now.
Are you hurt?
Y-you saved me, mister.
Oh my god, she woke up with a British accent.
I was just doing my job.
The gods.
They're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, mister?
Me?
I'm a police detective.
What is that?
There was like...
One of the... Oh my gosh.
One of the...
I think it was like a movie recently.
The one with like beatboxing puppy or whatever.
If you've heard of that.
Like...
In the beginning of the movie, she has like a...
A British accent.
And then...
And then like...
As part of like the lore explanation, she was like...
When I...
When I grew up, I lost my accent.
And it was very clearly like...
Like they didn't want to pay another British...
Another actor to do like a British accent when she was an adult or something.
Not the beatboxing puppy.
It's the same thing except opposite here.
She got scared so badly, she developed a British accent.
That whole movie is literally AI?
I don't think it was though, wasn't it?
Like the...
Apparently it was some YouTuber that had been like creating it for a really long time.
And was like...
This is my...
Masterpiece movie!
But it was just not good movie.
Anyway...
Me?
I'm a police detective.
Okay.
So that's why you became a detective, huh?
That's right.
He was my ideal of what a detective was all about.
But an ideal detective doesn't shoot and kill his own wife.
True.
Exactly.
That's why I didn't want...
That's why I want to prove that he didn't.
Cecil, I...
Did I really shoot you?
Oh my gosh.
She is just like her hero.
Where did that come from out of the blue?
I really don't remember.
I've tried and tried but I just can't.
Now I finally understand how you must feel.
And how hard it is to have your memory gone.
Your story erased.
But who knows?
Knowing the truth might be even harder.
I'd rather believe there's hope myself.
Nice.
We should almost be done with this chapter though, right?
Dang!
She ate the whole thing!
That was great!
Do I have chicken on my face?
You're staring.
I bet you're thinking about how impressed you are with the way I took care of that chicken.
Just tell me one thing.
This case you say you're looking into...
Is it Detective Jouds?
What if it was?
I... I can't keep it from you.
It's too cruel.
Uh-oh.
Oh no, he's about to die before he tells us the information.
What are you talking about?
I'm sorry, Lin.
It's... it's tonight.
Oh, oh, okay, okay, never mind.
His execution.
Detective Jouds, you know...
It's tonight.
His execution.
But there's still time.
I looked into it and I found out all the executions in this country are carried out at dawn.
That may be the norm, but...
Not this time, I'm afraid.
What?
The execution is set for 11 p.m.
Oh my gosh, wasn't it 9?
What did you say?
It's going to happen pretty soon.
Oh!
Isn't there anything we can do to stop it?
Of course not.
It's too late now.
Not without a stay of execution from the Justice Minister.
I'm going to see him then.
What?
See who?
Who else?
The Justice Minister!
Don't be ridiculous!
There's not enough time!
I'm going!
Cecil!
Me?
Get to the prison!
Stop that execution!
Easy enough for you to say.
Detective Ranger, I'll be going now.
Okay, I'll let you go this time.
I'll tell him I was distracted because I was eating chicken.
He's a good guy.
Is there anything else I can do?
Could you find Camilla?
She's supposed to be on her way here.
Oh, your little Camilla?
Okay, you got it.
I'll look for her.
Okay.
You know what to do, Cecil.
You have to save Detective Jowd!
Runs away.
Yippee!
The life of yet another person I'm connected to is somehow about to end tonight.
Could it be a coincidence?
Or is there something more behind it all?
Detective Jowd is destined to be executed tonight.
I don't know if that fate is the wrong one for him or the right one.
But I've decided to go to the prison anyway.
Okay...
Wait, I'm sorry.
The 10.05 to 10.55 chat...
Okay, wait.
So it's supposed to happen in five minutes?
No way.
This is... I'm glad that we just finished because my throat has been killing me.
I think it's...
a good point to end.
Wait...
Oh!
Sorry, my bad.
I just realized I just turned off the music.
I turned off the wrong thing.
There we go.
Okay.
You're leaving us?
Yeah.
Sorry.
This is so fun!
I hope you guys are enjoying the story so far.
What are we?
Chapter select?
Thank you!
So we're at Chapter 8 out of 18.
So...
Gosh, there's still so much to go!
There's still so much to go.
I'm really invested in the story now.
Thanks for the stream.
I hope you have a restful sleep tonight.
Thank you!
Thanks for the stream, Tensai.
Cute, odd, ghost detective.
Looking forward to more of this game.
Thank you so much!
Yeah, we're not even...
We're not even halfway, man.
That's crazy.
So probably two, three more streams.
I'm gonna aim for two, though.
I'm gonna aim for two.
I would like to finish it before I leave for...
I can finish it before I leave for Off-Kai.
For sure, for sure, for sure.
Yeah.
The rabbit hole is deep.
It is!
Nice!
But yeah, for those who are watching the story for the first time, I hope you're liking it.
For those who...
For those who are...
...fans of the game or played it before, I hope you are liking my playthrough.
Hopefully my brain is expanding at enough rate for your... to be satisfying.
Thanks for the stream.
I love this game so much.
Glad you're enjoying it.
Tomorrow I have an exam and I'm pretty nervous.
Wish me luck.
Good luck, Conqueror!
You are the Conqueror with the Von Karma...
...Francisco Von Karma profile picture.
You've got this!
You're going at a pretty good pace.
Says guy who loves this game.
Cool, cool, cool.
I'm gonna go get some more tea.
And I'm gonna go to sleep.
What am I doing tomorrow?
Hold on.
Checking my schedule real quick.
Shashingo!
Which if you're not aware of what that game is, it's basically...
...a game where you take pictures and learn stuff in Japanese.
So we can learn Nihongo.
Let's learn Nihongo together!
Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Mike Taishan, thank you for the super chat!
Hope you have a good night.
You too!
You too, you too!
Yeah, so...
Let's learn Nihongo together!
I was wondering if you've listened to Atarashii Gakko.
I know they're not really the typical idol group.
Just wondering.
I have!
I have listened to them a little bit.
Thanks for the super chat!
Congrats on 200k!
Thank you!
Actually, I...
Oh my gosh.
I have pictures from an old...
Let me see.
I have to check how long ago this was.
That I...
I didn't realize it was...
Like I...
I had...
I had gone to the exhibit for something else.
But it was a collaboration with them as well.
It was like them and another brand.
Back in...
I'm looking through my pictures.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I posted the picture in 2016 but it said throwback.
So actually, I'm not sure.
When I posted the picture, it says throwback.
So actually, I don't know at all when this...
It might have been 2016.
That sounds right.
But yeah.
So I've known about them for a while.
But...
So it's really crazy to see that they...
But I never listened to them back then.
I was never like a huge fan.
But it's really crazy to see how popular they've become now.
They're like everywhere.
Eight years ago.
Yeah, right?
Okay.
I'm gonna go rest you guys as well.
I'll try to wear Ace Combat merch at Off-Kai.
I hope you will see me there.
But if unable to meet you during meet and greet...
Or unable to see me, I will post my merch on Twitter after...
Yeah!
Post it!
I will be at Off-Kai.
Bishoujo is very kind enough to let me be in one of the little robots as well.
So Matara and I will be going around in our robots.
And if you don't get a meet and greet...
If you can't go to the con...
Sorry.
But if you don't get a meet and greet at the con...
We will be...
We'll be also going around as well.
They sold out?
What the...
The meet and greets?
Oh, the con sold out!
I was gonna say, I don't think the meet and greets are sold.
They're a lottery.
But also...
If you can't make it to Off-Kai...
Maybe another time and place.
Hopefully.
We'll do our best.
Yeah.
Um...
But yeah!
Otsuminto everybody!
Thank you so much for joining me again today!
And we will finish the game!
Uh...
Eventually.
Can you and Matara do like BattleBots and fight each other?
I sure hope so.
I demand Mint to fly to our houses in drone form.
For all the people who missed it.
Hey, I possess you guys sometimes.
Isn't that enough?
Okay.
Oh...
It's late.
Get a lot of rest, you guys!
Otsuminto!
Bye-bye!
Have a good night!
Bye!
Bye-bye!
See you!
Bye!
Ouch.
I always forget to turn this off.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
Bye.